I like doing that almost a bit good
evening everybody my name is Andy Crump
I will be chairing tonight's planning
committee be and tonight we'll be
looking at the planning merits of the
applications in front of us before we
start the meeting i recurse everybody to
make sure their phones are either on
silent or switched off because there's
nothing worse than being interrupted by
the tuned The Great Escape
sometimes as cancers we would like to
escape from the meeting but
unfortunately we have to say to the end
furthermore only people are ready to
speak are led to speak at this meeting
and please do not shout out however
tempting it might be you might totally
disagree what the speaker or the officer
is saying please not shout out that will
be very much appreciated but like a
schoolteacher I can have my orders we
have to get canceled Kendall Wright
[Music]
introduced the top table place Thank You
chairman lists of Oscar committee
services major - legal services we use
combine Senior Planner
Paul Thompson planner it's Gulati
planner the most observant among sure
you may have noticed the lights to my
left is not spoken I will introduce
Karen who's got a special role with his
committee and she will explain what that
role is now thank you - my name is Karen
Tate
I'm the planning manager for tonight's
meeting my role is to provide impartial
advice to clarify any planning issues
that arise and to assist members in
their decision taking unbound by the
Royal Town Planning Institute code of
Professional Conduct planning committee
members are not found by advice from
officers or from the recommendations
thank you right we'll move on to the
first item on the agenda which is
polishes for absence
apologies from counsel each unit and
hazarat substituting and apologies from
counselor kettle thank you thank you
catch the rock nice to see you
and you saw you yesterday can't keep
away item 2 disclosures of interests any
items against the rock Thank You
chairman I'll declare an interest in the
application 1901 635 item 6 is in my
ward I shall be stepping down from from
the committee when the item is
considered I further declare a personal
interest in this application that I've
discovered seven days ago that the
applicant is a solicitor whose client I
have been for a number of years and
whose services I last used five years
ago after taking advice from legal and
planning officers I intend to speaking
objects into that application on
planning grounds thank you cash bonds
I've got an application from Welford I
went to the Bears council last night
told them it was on they found out they
didn't object now because it James
presumably no speakers yeah we do agenda
and I grant application interest in
application 19-inch slash zero one five
so tonight if you are on Brooklyn's farm
what roadside them on water number so I
will be withdrawing from Committee on
that one
thank you next item is are you happy for
me to confirm and sign the minutes of
the meeting count on the 18th of
September very smoothly we move on to
the first item item number on the agenda
first planet application which is
applications
yes trying to go too fast more haste
less speed we've got two items that here
for this meeting you're here because of
parish council objections first one is
application 1901 96 slash ful rib meat
Barton arrow Alfred von Ivan and I
believe the price Council withdrawn that
application so because it was here
because of an objection
I would hope our request and the
committee agrees to delegate that so
sorry counselor them so you're happy to
agree my okay so as you happy it's a
second yep so all those in favor Karen
so community agrees to delegate
application 19 / 0 1 9 6 0 f you our two
offices and the next one is 19 /
mitem turn its lesson on the agenda 19 /
0 0 9 7 light ful again here because of
parish council objection
now I'm not here tonight again and again
under delegated powers on happy to
propose that we delegate this
application to officers I'm just looking
for a second door on that one okay so
the fielding all those in favor of
delegating that one Thank You Council
Committee agrees to resolves to delegate
application 19 /c Rizzo 978
a few are 39 high streets Dudley to
offices right n Louise we will now move
on to our next item this is application
number 18 / 0 2 3 4 1 / ful the land
east and west of hitting tonight whilst
borne erection of up to 17 dwellings
with associated infrastructure and
person present it officer is Louise
Thank You Louise
Thank You chair all right the
application site is identified by black
dot on the map and it's located on the
southern edge of wells born village
which is classified and the core
strategy is a main rural center this
site is located within the built-up area
boundary of wells born as defined in
both the wells born in Walton
Neighborhood Development Plan and also
in the core strategy the site isn't
within the conservation area and there's
no list of buildings within or adjoining
the site itself the site lies within a
larger development which which has been
granted permission for 350 dwellings and
outline application 15400 5 9 6 o UT and
two subsequent reserved matters
applications for 223 dwellings and 127
dwellings therefore all 350 have
permitted the application site is
identified in the area red on the plan
and is located in an area of land
situated in the northeastern part of the
site and the application is for an
additional 17 dwellings this would link
into the wider residential development
which is already under construction a
large area of open space lies to the
east of the site and this land required
to provide an attenuation pond a public
open space and also a leap under the
earlier reserved matter permissions and
the residential development known as
editin Park lies to the north the site
is accessed off the Eddington Road by
the adjoining persimmon housing
development and pedestrian access to the
site can be achieved off Edington Road
here
Walton Road and also through the
adjoining exiting park development in
order to get context with the approved
development and how it fits into this
this is the first phase of the 350
dwelling so this is for the first 223
units as you can see this is the area
identified and under consideration this
evening where the 17 is now proposed
this is the last phase of the 350 so as
you can see this was approved under
delegated powers this is the area which
is being excluded and this is what's
coming forward this evening in terms of
the layout the the site links into the
adjoining Street hierarchy with a main
thoroughfare leading to a smaller Drive
the proposed layout allows natural
surveillance of the streets and open
spaces joining and a mix of one two
three and five four and five bed units
are being proposed with 35% being
affordable the affordable houses
priors for affordable rent into shared
ownership units which have been
supported by our housing enabling
officer the dwellings are proposed to be
two-story in height actually and also in
terms of the location of the affordable
units at their start here this unit 50
is actually two units these are the two
one bet units in terms of the design of
the dwellings the design and form as you
would expect your upon a local
vernacular and also mirror that of the
adjoining persimmon development so
here's a flavor of the dwellings which
are being proposed so turning to their
photographs this is taken from within
the site Oh whiz back this is taken
aware the development is currently
finishes so I'm along this road here I'm
looking towards the application site
here going across what's currently just
a soiled area but that's going to become
the neap so that's the context so there
we go that's not the view this is the
etting Patton Park development is it all
the wet day I'm afraid so these are
Mouser soil which is going to be removed
but this is the area of land the
existing network of internal roads which
would actually also serve this
development and this is a view from the
adjoining Edington park the Charles
Church developments looking across into
the area of the site so these are the
these are the existing houses within the
joining persimmon development so that's
within the site itself there were the
wider sale site itself
this is the neap area here just to give
you some context of what's already being
built there's one update which is in the
update sheet and the recommendation
chair is
I grant the application a subject to the
completion of a section 106 and the the
clauses for the section 106 are outlined
in their report thank you - Thank You
Louise hopefully your Wellington's on
when you walk through the right move on
to our first speaker was just catch that
vampire stream it's no surprise far away
when you're ready Thank You chairman
councillors this application originally
came to Crouch council as a means of the
developers to fulfill their affordable
housing needs for the original planned
and agreed development of 350 houses in
that development they'd not met the 35%
affordable houses Stratford District
Council insisted that the criteria
should be met in the original
development and the reserve matters were
then approved by the parish council we
did not expect a further planning
application for these 17 houses the
parish councils strongly objects to his
application it is country to our made
neighborhood plan which is part of your
core strategy map 11 in our neighborhood
plan identifies of the area to the north
west of the village for any new housing
development up to 2030 one and indeed
stated that this plot should not be
released until after 2021 when we
anticipate that all the current
developments will be completed I would
remind councillors that during the
period of this core strategy wells borne
has already had eight hundred and thirty
houses granted for development and this
proposed development on the land of the
attention rode along with infill housing
would bring our total to over nine
hundred houses this our total expected
development in the district a fourteen
thousand five hundred homes by 2031
we believe that Wells one has taken more
than its share the required housing in
the district indeed in 2016
without this future further development
we as one of the main eight main rural
centers had already provided 22 percent
of the houses allocated to all of the
rural centers your planning officer
considers quote that the erection of 17
dwellings would be considered to be
small in scale in relation to the size
of wells for and there forward to dare
to the policy ww7 of the wells borne of
altered neighborhood plan we strongly
disagree we understood that our
neighborhood plan carried legal weight
and this statement shows a lack of
understanding of the importance of our
neighborhood plan the neighborhood plan
makes it clear that there should be no
further development south of the village
already the current developments are
stringing out the village with new
residents being increasingly distance
from the village itself even to the
extent that whilst they are told that
their catchment school is counting they
then find that they're not given free
transport to it because their houses are
outside the transport area sorry I just
lost my second bit of paper
this is not infill building which
couldn't be the only point the obviously
referring to this is a new developed of
700 701 area of open space open space
which is sadly lacking in the village
when our neighbourhood plan was written
we had we had using figures from
Stratford District Council a deficit of
0.78 hectares of open space in circles
Republic we should not be in the
business as a planning committee of
losing us open space that would help to
rectify some of that deficit yes we
would agree the areas within our defined
built-up boundary but additional
development contrary to the offices
assertion should not be here it should
if required glute area one of the
neighbourhood plan to northwest of the
village
if neighbourhood turns up to me anything
it's there just finish my sentence ok
thank you I'm nearly there if they decay
the legal wages we suggested they do
then you as counselors should know their
service to them mastermind I've started
so finish isn't it right then catch the
boys you've indicated it's a made
neighborhood planning is now forms part
of your contract thank you very much
good evening yes I your neighbourhood
plan was adopted in I think 2018 wasn't
it yes it was agreed with the
neighbourhood plan that anymore de belem
will be north of the mrs. self that's
right that's correct all north of the
village that was what was agreed in the
neighbourhood plan ok and what only on
this particular development was there
any consultation with the parish council
No
this is space you say was open space yes
nominated as public open space will did
it covering usual and it been allocated
to be green space or whatever before the
application for The Hague is winning it
was open space on the development open
space which we're in discussion with the
developers to take over as a parish
council obviously it's in the vu IB and
according to the the plan it's an area
or do you approve for development in
your same you if I was listening
properly and I used to tell me off when
I was at school for not listening you
said for 2021 you looking forward and it
was up what
tie him up correctly this wasn't all
agree with the development the original
development that we agreed to was three
hundred and fifty houses on the
development east and west of edgington
Road this is a further 17 houses the
area that's identified in our
neighborhood plans to the northwest of
the village it's identified as area one
on the map if you have our neighborhood
plan and the overwhelming view of the
village was we wanted no further housing
in the south of the village this is on
what was open green space which base as
I say supposed to come to parish council
any more questions for the Park answer
thank you can fly you know free to go
thank you we've got no further speakers
on believe registered to speak on a
supplication so we'll go two points of
clarification with officers please
do I assume that the ward member still
agreed with what he put in the agenda he
supported there has been an update cat
scandal a mid sentence stating it is
happy for the application be determined
delegate to Paris this has been carried
over from the previous report related to
reserve matter application on the site
in an error you know care about council
bonds ok Kessler filled in no it's not a
problem that has more than enough open
space always it do do they need more
open space within that development thank
you
no it's not in in in terms of the
requirements for the 350 units the it
doesn't impinge on the open space
requirements as set out in the the
public open space calculations sets out
on the original outline and then has
been carried over in the reserve matters
so no it doesn't impinge on it I don't
know whether I heard you right but there
is only one access to this site because
I've got the feeling you were talking
about one to the north and one to the
east just just to clarify there is a
pedestrian access available
sorry it's here in this within the
persimmon development itself so this
application will effectively be
intrinsically linked with the remaining
housing site and the links as they'll be
physical links there's there's a
footpath route
let me just pull it up here maybe it
slightly easier for example this is this
is the face this is the reserved matters
approval you can see a slightly clearer
there's there's a walk way around the
development this development was also
have footways this is the approve road
up to this point here anyhow so it would
be able to be linked to Edington park it
would be able to utilize the footpaths
from etting tonneaus and also Casals
obviously this is all open space to the
east and it does have access onto the
wealth Walton Road as well look at
something else next time they will come
back to you again job thanks mr.
chairman I'm not sure this one for
hashing for Mesa but the neighborhood
plan which we'll go through the moment
how legal is this neighborhood plan is
this is this one for the reason adopted
and as part of the actual core strategy
it is the same wait yes same wage okay
fine that's funny to know
thank you very much children it's a
large site and the houses at the far end
is there a bus route running around this
or is it just going to be in a position
where people have got to have vehicles
and therefore under our new approach
to climate change are we going to insist
on something to do with putting asking
the developer to deal with something
along the climate change problems
teacher yes in terms of the wider
development there were a series of
requirements for the 350 unit houses to
come forward their requirement for two
bus shelters there's a contribution of
320 thousand pounds towards the
provision of a new bus service to serve
the development for a five-year period
so that is coming forward irrespective
of this development
now when highways commented specifically
for the 17 that's not a figure which
would require additional generations of
funds towards that five-year provision
so but but there is now going to be
services available for this site I don't
believe that they go into the site I
think is theirs bus stops are along
Eddington Road itself so there's going
to be to provision of two bus stops on
the road itself so there's a no bus
going into the side I don't think into
the site itself
I think elderly people if they're
elderly people living in the social
housing I that obviously is a
consideration however I would just
amplify that that is also a
consideration for the adjoining houses
which have been permitted under the
reserve matter development within here
and as it is required under policy
there's social housing is Pepperpot it
throughout the development itself so
that's the only point I would just like
to
was to do with time to change are we
putting but powerpoints for charging up
vehicles I have requested a condition to
require that yes yep Bright Angel that
catch the bonds within this development
this particular part of the development
actually they are the closest to the
road networks it's they're not in the
end touch the mouse if it may come back
this Chairman can page 15 on fifth
paragraph down this is I consider the
erection of 17 dwellings will be
considered too small in scale in
relation to the size of wells born and
therefore would appear to policy ww7 of
the wells walnut water the neighborhood
plan okay sorry I'm you might I could
you explain that to me because as I
understand parish council it is not in
their book plan but you're saying it
ideas to the neighborhood plan but sorry
I don't quite understand extract from
the wells borne neighborhood plan may
may assist within their policy the
policy refers to map 11 I have to
confess I haven't got a slide of that
but it doesn't matter I can show you the
location so the preferred area of
development is this area here I
identified this area one also in areas
two and three here so that they're
wanting to target development to the
north and east of the settlement now
obviously the site which we're referring
to this is the wider site this is areas
of where we're saying the open space is
here and the application site is in this
section of land in here which is already
that's what we are referring to is an
area already identified for development
it's not imp engine into this area
identified as open space so in terms of
the policy yes
the policy does in ww7 refer to the
these three areas to be targeted and
development to be put towards the the
north and east of the district but it
there is the paragraph within it and I
think it up I've highlighted in it
saying that it does go on and say that
small infill developments within the
built-up area boundary will be supported
in principle where these complement the
design of surrounding buildings and
provide satisfactory
arrangements for access and off-road car
parking it is within the bill to vary
boundary and from an officer perspective
I consider that it is to those
parameters Castle Rock I wasn't
proposing to add a question but I will
now the word infill thing which you just
mentioned would you agree the only
reason this would comply with the
neighborhood plan which specifically
excludes areas to the south is because
you consider this to be infill that is
the only reason it would comply the
neighbor plant which I read before I
came to the committee it's a red infill
that's the reason it would comply in
your view yes Jo I think there is some
confusion around this matter the the
site in question 350 which is this area
which is which the current proposal says
was already committed at the time that
the neighborhood plan was made so there
was an outline consent for development
of this area which is why it's
identified within this within this map
in the neighborhood plan because there
was already the principle established
now
the reason that you have an application
for a full application which is sitting
within the red line area of the outline
consent is because the earlier phases
added up to three hundred and fifty
dwellings so the reserved matters we
have on that line consent for three
hundred up to three hundred and fifty
dwellings the two reserved matters that
were submitted where it's slightly
harder density which which achieved the
three hundred and fifty this this left a
residual piece of land which was always
intended to be developed for for housing
as you see from the original outline
master plan the reason that you have a
full application as opposed to a
reserved masters application is because
this breach because this can't be
compliant with the requirements of the
outlined consent which gave a limit of
three hundred and fifty so as a
consequence the developers or a
developer would have to apply for a full
planning permission on this piece of
land although the principle had
effectively been established under the
outline consent okay so I see you want
to come back so this adds seventeen to
the numbers beyond that approved in
outline yes fundamentally that it
happens to be with you within the area
that was approved in outline yes so if
if the developer had built is his or her
three hundred and fifty houses and taken
on land look we won't have miss
if the developer did he'd got no
information had used all of the spice
flat 350 we wouldn't be having this
application because these spices been
left over it's been an area of of
already proved development but because
it's five percent over these extra
seventeen yeah quite quickly they've had
to come back and say this is a new
application because they've only got
approval to build 350 in that area of
land not 367 yes I think just to clarify
had the developer reduce the two
developers on the main part at all the
phases that have already been granted
the reserved matters application had
reduced that number by seventeen and
this had been submitted as a reserved
matters application for seventeen years
that would have been secured under the
outline consent as a reserve matters the
fact they exceeded this on the two
phases means that they they are required
to make a full application caso Flynn
something requires counselor said about
they had an agreement that this was
going to be green open space was there
ever a commitment from the Builder to
the district council or to the parish
council that it was going to be greener
in the space and neither have they had
gone back on it has there been a
misunderstanding so that said that we
know back building on what was going to
be green space this is the indicative
outline plan this this was for the
outline application services for their
original 350 this is why the line is
drawn as it is on both the neighborhood
plan and also in our core strategy you
can see this is the area of currently
into consideration so it's it's though
with an outline you just outlined the
principle but nevertheless in the core
strategy and the neighborhood plans they
use this as a guide now in terms of the
areas of public open space and in terms
of requirements to have an attenuation
basins working obviously to serve that
to serve the wider site
it was always envisaged that this area
was going to be utilized for that and
also they provide an additional leap in
this area as well now in terms of the
requirements for 350 units they were way
exceeding the requirements for public
open space vastly exceeding the
requirements so that's this additional
area of land in terms of well in terms
of assessments when we do calculations
for requirements for equipped and also
amenity space there is a requirement for
an off-site provision it's a standalone
application that we're looking at
tonight but for the in consideration for
the wider development certainly they
were way exceeding their requirements
but it crucially it's not in impinging
within that zone
right I think we've no further questions
should we go on to the debate then
please let's cancel the rock as I said a
moment ago I am studied in some depth
the neighbourhood plan adopted for wells
born before I came here
it seemed absolutely clear to me that
developments to be centred on the north
and it specifically excludes development
in this area the only exclusion to that
is infill properties so this to my mind
descends to the word in English as to
what's an infill now the office is quite
rightly looked at that as to what an
in-floor can mean and has used the
context of infill in the size of the
settlement says it's quite a large
settlement it's only 17 houses that is
an argument that I understand but I
can't agree with because you could say
well if it's London it could be very
large very large infill I can't agree
with it it seems quite clear to me than
the wells born neighbourhood plan
specifically excludes a development of
that type we ask people to do these
neighbor plans we adopt them as my book
pass they they form part the core
strategy if if the developers built 350
as a limit however they've distributed
on that site was up to them they can't
come along now and say that because it
seems to be completely out with the
requirements in the wells borne
neighborhood plan and I'm afraid I can't
support this application I think we
should refuse it well might have to come
back for reasons for that but we'll
listen to the rest of DeVoe ok so
fielding and then catch something else
going back onto the neighborhood plan
was the neighborhood plan completed
before this I came up against the failed
him really this should have been a
publication big because the debates all
that you carry on because if this was
knotting if this was including within
the development neighborhood plan then
just just to finish it off which is what
we're talking about I would have thought
is it's an appropriate thing to do but
what annoys me what was sorry what
upsets me is we're trying to deal with
climate change and there are no public
transport on a site this size where
people are going to have to rely on cars
yes I can understand the list
development yes I suppose I would
support it but I do have reservations I
think we got there in the end
catch the bombs yes this is a typical
one I feel sorry for well born that
they've got eight to nine hundred asses
should have four hundred hit live well
food was supposed to have eighty eight
hundred and ninety but it looks to me as
though this was in the plan before the
the parish plan was done in my eyes and
and I feel it in planning to and
difficult to refuse but I'm concerned
about it certainly the as far as I can
see the affordable homes the old people
and the children will be nearest the
road to get the bus which is something
which is a good thing but looking at it
there I have sympathy for the buyers
council the ward member hasn't made any
comments so he obviously yet is in limbo
whatever he wants to be well you know so
I would have to go along with the
opposite I'll propose
well see if there's any more points to
the debate council knows you indicated
in the inside
thank you Miss Jim yes Oh try not to
repeat counter rock we said but I'm not
happy with this but it's contrary to
well as borns Neighborhood Development
Plan you know they did state to be in
the North this is in the South I'm
really really for they bought plans we
had one kind and that was wait yeah we
might well not not happen April plan as
far as I'm concerned if we throw this
out you know but so mr. chairman I'm not
happy for this I will unfortunately soil
away topic going against the office of
the commendation on this thank you
because notification yeah I too agree
I'm not happy with it it's outside the
neighborhood plan it's south where they
weren't supposed to be building anymore
so I just don't agree with having been
subject to situations like this myself
in parish where I live we were
encouraged to to have neighborhood plans
to protect the villages from
overexposure and and other things and
the thing that concerns me is that post
councillor was saying that they had an
agreement that it was going to be
increase space well if you don't invent
that sort of thing so it sounds to me as
though something has changed and so I'm
very unhappy with it with the extra
squeezing in of 17 houses in this space
right at the moment we've got a proposal
from catch the bonds to grow up with the
officers recommendation have we a
seconder for not catch the fielding so
we've got a proposal on the second debt
to
agree the officers recommendation to
grant a subject to a section 106
agreement I'll be happy to go to the
boat on this all those in favor of
approval of this application please
sorry chairman those against for German
so that fails that falls so therefore we
will need an alternative proposal I
believe catch the rock is going to do I
propose we refuse this application
channel on the grounds that it does not
comply with ww7 the wells born and
Walton neighbourhood plan on the ground
that it's it's not in fill it is a
separate development contrary to their
requirement that development should be
focused on the north whatever the words
are stated in their plan you know the
current just wants to go in on chair
clarification purposes can I take you
back to map 10 please this is this is
the map that identifies the sites for
allocation in the neighborhood plan the
site lies within a an a not an
allocation but don't identified area for
development this is not a new
development site this is an existing
site identified within the neighbourhood
plan as already consented
so we're not we're not talking about a
new wholly new site coming forward we're
talking about a site which is already
accepted as part of a larger site within
the neighborhood to plan compute
computer kinds in here as always but not
what post else was saying they're saying
it's not in the neighboring development
confused here they've said it's not in
their development plan you were saying
is part of yes if I can I'm not sure
whether we can employ this up any any
larger it is it is within it is within
the built-up area boundary and it's no
and it is the annotation in the
neighborhood plan math for this area
yeah
colored in orange so this larger area
which includes the three hundred and
fifty houses already built and this part
of the land is specifically specifically
referenced as areas already approved for
development it is not a new it is not a
new speculative site it's a site which
the neighborhood that Wells for have
already identified as being part of a
larger development site this is sitting
as part of a development site already
the issue I think the issue from for you
is the number of houses the expectation
and the number of houses fixed 350 is
already secured by to reserve matters
which have used a smaller amount of of
the outline consented rounding in
question which has left a residual
parcel which always was anticipated
under the outline consent to be
developed
in terms of the reserve masters I
understand that when those applications
were submitted they were submitted with
the no objection from the parish council
so therefore the 350 was was on the
table predating this
application okay so well I'm guilty of
not printing off the neighborhood plan
before I came but I read it and it was
quite clear that it says further
development which would be beyond this
350 and not talking about the areas
outside further development we should be
directed to the north of the settlement
so the only reason it breach says it
except for in fills so if there's a
debate that we accept that 17 houses can
being filled it would be compliant if we
don't accept that 17 houses is infill it
seemed to me and I haven't got the words
in front of me but it's somewhere in the
neighborhood plan it's a further it's a
further development beyond that that's
already been approved therefore its
outside that the words in English I mean
not a planner but the words in English
so further developments a further
development because the 350 has been
fulfilled it surely it's at with those
though outside those words if we accept
is not infill it's only infill that
would permit it it in my interpretation
but I am reading English rather than
planning speak I hope that this was
agreed to be a sight to be used for
housing previously under the original
reserved matters
am I correct in saying that the
implication to me is I'm not happy with
it but the point really is it looks to
me as though it's already been sort of
approved I think I think the crux of the
matter is that the site has been at the
reserve matters I think the crux of the
matter is that it's the numbers on this
I think that's what the position is as
far as I've read in this and I'm sure
myself if I'm not reading it correctly
so therefore
the site is okay and it's been approved
it was just the arguing the argument
between the 350 or the 367 on that side
so whether the new houses are north or
the sides or so at the situs in akhom -
your second job in the neighborhood plan
I don't think the areas of are in
contention here I think it's the numbers
so that's what we've got to be so go to
John we don't have a specific date
within the neighborhood plan that
identified but there is a reference to
October 2018 catch the prior can you
come forward yes please if you want to
come forward just a minute I'll come
back to you a second John sir there with
me can you please tell us when you it
was fine your neighborhood plan it was
actually receive full approval under the
process that strap addition Kansas go
through it was voted on in 2000 the end
of 2016 we went to referendum in 2016
he was actually adopted there was a gap
between the referendum case the fielding
I think if I heard the officer right the
when this site was put forward there was
certain amount of open spaces and they
found that they'd over allowed open
spaces so therefore this site that was
being put as a reserve for open spaces
suddenly became redundant and therefore
it could be built on is that correct
no this site the two thousand at the
point that the the neighborhood plan was
was married the outline consent had been
in place since October 2015 the first
reserved matters was approved in January
2017 so that the reserve maps of the
site was underway effectively at that
point the outline consent had a master
plan the master plan but it gave a
strong indication of where the where
development was expected to take place
and if you look at the neighborhood plan
the neighborhood plan that yeah marries
up with that line so the line the line
along here when you look at the
neighborhood plan map you have a an area
which is crosshatch which is which is
shown as a second
secondly unreal secondary open space
area the open space area this is the
area that followed effectively the
initiative outlined permission so the
neighborhood plan had an expectation of
housing on this parcel of land I've got
a question which I should have asked as
the party when she was here so can can
you come back again I'm sorry about this
but I want to clarify this in my own
mind when I heard you correctly
when you're speaking earlier you
mentioned the Year 2021 I know that did
you say that you didn't expect any more
buildings or development on that side
until after 2021 until all the other
other developments have been built or
did I miss understand you completely
misunderstood me what I actually said
was we don't we didn't expect any more
development on this site at all the
original planning application was for
350 houses which have been agreed and we
agreed to those the area one which is
our identified area for any future
developments before 2031 we said in our
development plan we would prefer that
that didn't happen until 2021 until all
are with the developments had finished
not that we were expecting to have more
developments in that area and I'd
seriously question the sort of comments
we'll be making the a excuse me excuse
me sorry no no no that's not the
question sorry sorry I apologize
right I think we we are sort of clear on
not now having a lot of pills I'm just
wondering Council rocks put forward the
actual neighborhood development policy
which will be argued both sides but also
I'm just looking at what the developers
barrister could put forward being within
the superior boundary the principle
developments the harm you know 17
additional houses would take so there's
a lot more for him or her to fight
against artists than just putting
forward the actual neighborhood policy
I've been film so I'm just advising you
that when we go to if and would like to
go to appeal that our case is just one
thing which is the actual neighbourhood
policy where the other side will put all
these points forward I think that was a
request for more reasons for the
potential refusal
that wasn't yet that was actually just
advise members that there's a lot more
considerations and just putting one
policy forward I think members are
requested if possible to come forward
more reasons if we if it did go to
appeal so I can understand what Castle
Rock has come from on on the
neighborhood plan but all the other
reasons as well so usually we're up two
or three when we would come up with our
over approval against officers
recommendation or vice versa so I mean
it's quite ambiguous all this isn't it
either is or isn't in the neighbor
development plan you're saying this was
already decided
I personally their reason I've got is
it's totally against neighbourhood plan
and and this Mesa said it holds as much
weight as now cost actually just say so
but the NDP doesn't mean that's you know
applications a resisted full stop you
still have to assess what's in the
neighborhood plan and all other material
considerations that might enable plan
and was happening kinds of hosel say it
is a material consideration that we have
to take in town what I would also add
therefore but exceeds the number of
houses in the adjacent plots noting it
was already in the reserved matters
sorry in the airline area but they've
implemented the reserved matters already
for the 350 which was an opted to limit
so it's only exceeds the numbers that
were already approved so I don't want to
put the tongue to put in a different
word but it looks like it's a device to
add another 17 home to the 350
appropriate it's a material exceeding of
the approve UPR that we need to be yes
nice in what language and that will
cause significant harm to X wine said
yeah I think that's the the thing we've
got to come up so it's another seventy
whatever the mechanism was to decide
upon 350 it's more traffic than was
anticipated there was a question as I've
been put forward
it's got affordable homes at the extreme
edge of the periphery of the development
that was previously approved there's a
matter that and some of those might be
for people who might need public
transport which is made made in the
debates and possibly that's that's some
of the reason being tapped on the edge
if that the scheme had been incorporated
throughout perhaps that would have been
addressed however it appears to be a
mechanism to get round to 350 I don't
know if those are points that can be
baked into planning speak but if want
some extra reasons they are
supplementary to the main one of it in
my view being beyond the limits of
what's in the neighborhood plan Jeff I
mean in terms of in terms of reasons for
refusal you have to show harm in
relation to a reason for refusal in the
overall scheme this site is sitting us
as an inn as a part of a much larger
development 350 dwellings so it's it's
an integral part of that effectively of
that scheme it uses its links and it's
developed effectively an association
with this with 350 houses in terms of
the layout if I can refer you to the
committee report there's a very detailed
analysis of how its considered to become
policy compliant policy complied in
terms of CS 19 CS 26 we have public open
space of contributions the affordable
housing meets our standards it meets our
policy compliance in
so the mix of the house types we don't
have one bedroom two houses but that's
the only area where it's deficit there
are there are 1-bedroom affordable
houses so it's compliant in in terms in
those terms in relation to where it's
located it's normal practice on phase
developments of larger larger sites tube
to have the affordable housing to
scattered pepper pottery throughout the
developments so this is not this is not
unusual in terms of a layout and the
proposed content and housing mix I think
it's important you know where some of
the earth or affordable houses are if
we're talking about that matter if I can
see on this plan here the two stars here
the stars here the stars here the stars
there they are affordable units and the
proposed affordable units are here so
just in relation to the context it's
there to there mr. fielding
the original development and all the
infrastructure the the roads have been
put in and everything else so we're
doing is just filling in a gap that was
there but it was also this was agreed
before the neighborhood plan was
finalized and created and therefore
we're not arguing about the neighborhood
plan were arguing about whether this
should be dealt with to finish the
scheme nice nickname basically the
committee has the right to go against
officers recommendation officers don't
always get we don't always get it right
but yeah we have a debate and we have to
come if we are going against officer
recommendations we need to make sure
that we're coming up with significant
and material reasons for going against
officers recommendations and as mayor
pointed out that we need to perhaps
something it's defendable if this went
to appeal so again I've got no problems
with that whatsoever this is fine it's
we've done that in the past and it shows
but what I'm hearing is we've got a list
of reasons that are you need to do a
neighborhood plan which again needs to
be firmed up and the other reasons are a
bit for income Wally it's it might be it
closer to the affordable housing it
might not have the infrastructure so I
think unless we come up with some strong
significant reasons we might be in
trouble so I'm trying not to lead the
committee but we've got to come forward
with something significant and
defendable and at the moment I'm not
really hearing up so that's where I'm at
so cancel the rock providers and catch
the mills seconded for refusal of this
application because of non-compliance
with the neighborhood plan by the local
parish council the number is exceeding
the reserve matters that were proved
earlier which the 350 in the outline
right so we've had that proposal we've
had it seconded so we'll going to the
fountain all those in find that are
refusing the application due to the
reasons mentioned by catch the Rockland
proposed Park and something else all
those in favor of that against
abstention
so that goes to me on the custom vote
and I will go with my against your
application against your proposal so
that proposal Falls so now we need
another proposal just what I did before
the offices recommendation I do have
concerns in greenfield site and that but
so you're proposing to go with approval
seconded
okay well we'll go to the game all those
in favor of agreeing to grant this
application please like that those
against and abstentions so again it goes
to my custom vote and I will keep with
my original decision and go with the
original prepare the proposer to grant
this application using my custom vote
thank you
so committee resolved to grant
application 18 0 2 3 4 1 / f you are
subject to section is subject to this
section 106 agreement
but move on to the next application and
please 19 / 0 1 8 2 4 ful fallens farm a
dance kit and our presenting officer is
Joan so far away when you're ready drip
and sorry about that capture
sorry man
thank you facilities located outside the
physical confines on the edges of dial
and Scott as indicated on black belt
before you the site is located off the
main road food that one's got an access
for an existing access seven for Dan's
farm the application seeking permission
for the two-bedroom bungalow with an
open field adjacent to foreland farm
the site is located off the main road
has already stated and it's all my fault
site visit the field is bound by
existing dentures Road to the north on
the west you can see the site areas here
and there is dense hedgerows there
fallens farm is situated here mr. Z
Jason pleasures farm the plan before you
also shows the distance between the
application and nearest neighboring
dwellings within the settlement boundary
at dial and Scott so you can see to the
west is 140 meters so near its dwelling
here and 125 meters to advance and all
I stated the application saw his
proposal I'm open parcel and to the
western edge of the village the eastern
Natori the site is bound by strip
evasion and presently situated in the
holdings of Orleans far so I was shown
in the previous month there is fallen
farm the red line shows where the
application is being proposed pleasures
families outside the applicants
ownership to the east the application is
prose and a single storey bungalow set
at 5.6 meters to ridge where a red brick
finish through Spanish lay and black
powder coated aluminium windows and
doors overall the application would see
a developer footprint of circuit 84
square meters as you can see represent
for you on the floor plans this is a
view of the site and the open pasture
land with some of the workings from
fallens farm this is as you can see
darling Scotland on the horizon nicely
application site area of approved this
is the access that leads into it fallen
farm is situated that way that's the
access into if approved from the main
road this is a neighboring pleasure farm
dwell in and you can see the road
leading into darkness got on your left
and that's the road leading into
Thailand Scott and the settlement
boundary of Dan Scott for all you
this is fallens farm which is adjacent
to the application site in conclusion
the application is seeking permission to
develop a walnut island outside his
confines of the village Dan Scott which
is identified and all of a sudden my
policy CS 15 of the core strategy the
development does not fall within any
development forum support imprints of
our core strategy policies is tense here
16 and is not considered to be fully
justified and therefore does not offer
significant benefits to locality also
recommendation for that reason is for
refusal
don't know what better thank you sorry
cancer hey sorry about that huh mumbling
the live without my microphone there we
got three minutes would you like a
warning with about 30 seconds yes okay
far away when you're a teacher
counselors good evening my name's Robert
Heath I'm here to speak on behalf of
treading temporis counsel Cheddington
Parish Council supports the fallens farm
playing application for mr. mrs.
Griffiths dwelling having looked at the
plans and having visited the site we
agreed that the small bungalow have
little impact on the street scene and
was neatly tucked away behind a hedge
with good access already from the road
and it was in keeping with the local
surroundings we also without looking at
curtilage ears and things of the village
felt that it's within the village
boundary cases within the village signs
and the 30 mile an hour speed limit
we've also noted that local support from
residents of darling skirt and the fact
that there's been no objections either
mr. and mrs. Griffin have been residents
in darkness took over 40 years that's a
separate address which they sold I think
proximately three years ago to allow
them to have the opportunity to fund
what we what we're seeing that
Portland's far they've grown a small
holding which provides a campsite for
caravans adding value to the local
community through tourism they also sell
farm laid eggs at the farm the property
provides storage for mr. Griffin's
machinery for his years as a builder and
a fencing contractor mr. Griffin is
still to this day cuts many of the
verges in the village and helps to keep
the village looking tied in a pleasure
to live in and travel through the parish
council are aware of the application
being sought through local needs
guidelines but without going into the
finer details
house prices availability we feel the
application of a small modest
two-bedroom bungalow which is just
enough for mr. mrs. Griffin to enjoy
their retirement and meets some of the
local needs criteria should the
application be granted mr. mr. Griffin
would be able to carry on living in the
community they've become so fond of and
that it would also be on site and to
look after their business and provide
the security that it needs in this day
and age and for those reasons
Reddington Parish Council support that
application thank you Miss Eve while
within time ashame some of the
councillors can't be Sabri cancer
fielding can we go back to believe
that's the case okay we can also ask the
agent is what wouldn't clarify that text
advisor you indicate or not on the
station if your village has a number
quota for houses no we do that for
clarification again cancel meals I've
got one slight concern obviously at the
moment the way this application has come
in it's even though you've eloquently
took us told us about the local needs
and the contributes and the applicant
contributes to the community etc and
it's got a business etc etc it's still
an open marked market application and
therefore what we needed there nothing
the opposite last one didn't get Megan
will BES any ideas as well was the
technical reasons to clarify this as a
local needs property so that's relaxed
our concerns and that's one that's the
main reason why he's been recommended
for a refusal
so again if
if you do have some example to come
forward to yourselves in the future
could you try and encourage the
applicant for these technical
information accepted to back this up of
course yes
any other questions right Thank You
counsel he you're free to go and now we
have cancer and no haven't we have the
agent she's Martin returnin and I've
he's probably been taking notes of some
of my questions and already as well
you've got three minutes mix mister turn
and join us morning with about 30
seconds or yes please get far away
please okay good evening the
pre-application feedback for local needs
to early support and design principles
but identified the need to demonstrate a
local link between the applicants and
the village and secondly to address the
belief that the house is located outside
of the perceived village boundary
colleagues who have lived in the village
of Darkness got for for nearly 40 years
previously in the southern corner
cottage some 240 meters from the
proposed new dwelling slide 2 of
presentation powerful and show the
screenshot taken from a Google Maps
search of darling Scots identified by
the red ping Google shows the the centre
of the village darlin Scott is in the
field immediately adjacent to four lands
farms and 30 meters west of the proposed
bungalow a local beans dwelling needs to
propose either accommodation for a rural
worker or to fulfill the requirements of
a housing needs server performance our
farm is home to more than a dozen hannes
provides available daily source of fresh
eggs with local people the farm also
provides requires very considerable
upkeep and management due to the camping
and caravan license which was kept
granted in 2014
posting up to five caravans and ten
tents at any one time there welcomed
regular annual visitors
undoubtedly benefits in local businesses
the plot falls outside of the
conservation area with Colin sue of an
emulated characteristics by planting
water trees from attaining mature
hedgerows they've attempted to implement
a new local housing needs survey having
completed the previous survey in 2013
the Parish Council comments from Joseph
Brook and Sarah brooke-taylor of works
rural community council have all
acknowledged that the local housing
needs survey is out of date but
currently there are no time scales for a
new survey in June 2019 a much larger
local needs dwelling on the western edge
of the village was approved without the
need for a local needs housing survey
our proposal is for a very modest 80
square metre bungalow complying with
policy cs50 we've taken into account the
local design guide the principles of the
nearby Conservation Area appropriate
screening by mature hedgerows and the
building line of the adjacent pleasure
farm which will also screen the new
dwelling thank you very much again one
within time questions for the agent can
suffer him to question is what you said
that's within the confines of the
village well as mentioned there by the
parish council remember that's it's 30
miles an hour outside of the outside of
the property is an existing entrance and
there is a sawing much further up the
road
staying welcome to darling Scots so
geographically I would think it would be
yes London one of the problems we have
at the moment is raw little crime I
don't know whether there is much there
so therefore having a property situated
there at the entrance would in some
respects help to deter people who like
to run
objects I agreed the name is there a
pleasure farm immediately it's the East
they too have suffered as I'll be
calling there it's his it's his current
farmstead they've had a number of
writings and the neighbors do welcomes
the presence of somebody else living on
site permanently with the permanent
address there okay so far was it sort of
considered that there would be an
agricultural Jai on this building any
today there's there we are welcome to
any suggestions from the council is
currently an agricultural toy to the
actual farm and that's been in place
since no I'd seen the ones you want okay
thank you touch the bonds yes I was just
wondering where the in terms of the
caravans were and whether this case was
being operas or is it the same yep the
caravans labels it would be the same
entrance it does fears off to the west
slight here so it's nothing's changing
with the access from the main road and
the y-axis is more than adequate so to
take if they can say caravans they can
take you know just very briefly it can
be skipped a bit more about the business
the caravans the the X etc and you know
the employment and again the benefits to
the local community and local persists
just a bit more information about that
things I mean it is a small-scale farm
in comparison to you know much larger
farms in the area but they have as I say
to have maybe 40 or 50 nights the year
where this people are actually staying
for the camping purposes that annual
visitors coming one of the one of the
letters of support that came in was from
an annual visitor to the farm to
describe and yes on a daily basis to
have people is a just at the just beside
the entrance that actually this will
shed their where there's the daily eggs
are put out and people come and just put
some money into the into the jar its
sort of hope you think it's a bit of a
little bit of a hobby but you know it's
it's an ongoing business
it supports local people they don't have
to travel because they can walk to
source their eggs and it limits a car in
the countryside
you said it been within the applicant
had been within the community 40-plus
years because that's correct yeah
thank you just to kiss up there's
actually nobody living on this site at
the moment
two people currently they are
temporarily living on the site and it's
under another application of the moment
some accounts have been reviewed to be
honest so basically they were living out
to certain cottage which was across the
across the road they put their property
up for sale and then the health concern
at the time meant their future home was
falling through and as previously
mentioned the the long-term plan was
always to develop they could do it's all
fully registered and the camping license
associated with the camping camping a
caravan all say teenis thank you very
much you're free to go
thank you right then we have our ward
member catch the Harvey
five minutes cancer harpy far away when
you're ready please the case officers
recommendation to refuse this
applications based on only two grounds
which are first lack of evidence to
establish the case for a local housing
needs dwelling and second that the site
of the proposed development is outside
the physical village confines CS 15
identifies the four key components of
the local need schemes such schemes must
first have the support of the local
community mr. mrs. Griffin demonstrably
have the support of the local parish
council in addition ten residents of the
village have written to express their
support for this application this
support is critical
CS 15 sets own stratford-on-avon
District Council will attach significant
weight to the fact that a parish or Town
Council is supportive C of 15 adds the
fact that a community wants a local need
scheme weighs significantly in its favor
secondly the scheme must respond to an
identified need CS 15 states that could
evidence of identification of need
should note should not must come from a
recent parish housing needs survey train
to parish councils most recent housing
needs survey was undertaken in 2013 it
is out of date and that is why the
council has decided to commission a new
survey mr. Griffin is approaching
retirement age he wants to make
provision so that he and his wife
it's got in their retirement the current
average price of a property in darling
squat
according to Zoopla is eight hundred and
twenty three thousand pounds by being
permitted to build on land they already
own mister mrs. Griffin can afford to
build a home appropriate to their
requirements and to their identified
need the third key component is the
establishment of a local connection mr.
Griffin handsomely fulfilled this
requirement having both lived and worked
in darling darling Scott for the past 40
years the final key component is that
the local need scheme should be
small-scale mr. Griffin seeks permission
to build one two-bedroom bungalow
development does not come much smaller
scale than this the evidence is there
for mr. mrs. Griffin mr. Sherman's
government's application meets all four
of the components of a local needs
scheme turning to the second ground for
recommending refusal the case officer
states that the site in question quote
is not considered to be within or
adjacent to the physical confines of
darling Scott we're on a map can a
resident fine but the physical confines
of Donald in the absence of the case
offices source for this arbitrary
concept of these confines most residents
would accept that these would be
established by the position of the for
welcome to darlings got road signs on
the respective fringes of the village
these signs sit either together with or
close to the 30 mile per hour speed
limit signs on entry to the village on
this basis the site in question is well
within the quote physical confines of
darling Scott by a matter of some 100
metres another way of establishing the
meaning of confines is to look at local
precedence in October last year an
application was approved by this council
for the building of a two-bedroom
bungalow
not dissimilar in scale to mr. Griffin's
application at firs Field
darling Scott that site is some 800
meters to the north east of darlings got
a distance very significantly further
away from its nearest adjacent house
than if the case would fallen far by a
factor approximately of eight I think I
should also point out that the decision
to approve that application was taken by
a committee upon which four members of
the present community participated I
think that similar independence of
evaluation and judgment is required at
the mr. Griffin's case to conclude mr.
chairman
there's ample evidence that this is an
application of genuine local need
supported by both the great weight of
the parish council and the local
residents it lies well within the
confines of the village as most ordinary
people would regard it and even more so
than by the president last year and by
the approval of the application
concerning first field Thank You mr.
chairman thank you very much mr. Harvey
questions for the ward member thanks the
building
views that can only recently carried out
in the country I took points from poor
strategy 15 but I think you can you can
establish that mr. Griffin's business as
a fencing contractor and small holder
and particularly as his business
operating in caravan site can't be
undertaken anywhere else I can you
further questions
No thank you co-star Harvey you're free
to go
thank you right points of clarification
for the offices now any points of
clarification has the bonds to approve
the application we would approve the
application could we put a condition on
a bet yeah local needs rather than an
open market property yeah you'd have to
be an obligation rather than no
condition so section 106 yeah surely an
actor
agricultural time would be more
appropriate cultural holding number the
whole point of a s 10 in in laulima
paragraph 790 m PP F is an assessment on
viability and functional need would be
needed also the African has stated that
they have a caravan license which isn't
considered an agricultural working unit
the whole separate assessment without
being taken to make sure is viable in
that location in accordance with the
core strategy
oh I just ask one question about the
local long so a lot of things that can
stir their harvey work were quite clear
and the local needs evidence of needs
was in the 2013 plan that was considered
out of date so therefore we need to look
at the flaw didn't we was there
indication of the local needs because
they're obviously the plan is in the
process of being locked out on on the
housing needs
there was no indication submit following
the applicant i think what is worth note
in a local needs writing was approved
there very recently in that application
which was also for local needs and
stipulated the african worker rule work
rule community each year on a housing
meet they which was then that house of
me so is further supported by a
traitor's embarrassed having civil then
local planning policy team then
supporting the principle of that there
was an evidence base behind it they were
put forward which was supported by the
parish council in this case we've had no
evidence base platform thank you thank
you
alright should we move on to the divine
annum a fairly requirement particularly
with regards to all the problems now
we're getting with her or crime they
have got to have some sort of ability to
protect their land and protect the the
caravans there are long established
members of the community they do a lot
of work within the community and there
to deprive them of a home and from the
what it sounds like is one member of the
families not very well but to provide a
small bungalow that is well hidden I
feel that we ought to go ahead with it
and I propose that we accept this and go
against the officers that's the bond sir
yes I really didn't really after the
village boundary there is a need I would
want a number of conditions on but I
feel this you know I could go along with
this
it's not in my eyes and open countryside
it obviously needs an office relief with
a caliber which today's virtually you
know 365 days a year and their wares
many years ago was only a few weeks to
the summer but I think no more
development on the site and a tie to the
businesses I could go along with that
thank you sir yes I totally agree that
local housing for local people as coughs
LaVon said we could make a condition on
it today if it came on the market it
would be for local people okay
I think Carol Nelson and Mesa will come
in thanks me Jimbo looked at this I
thought gosh it is it makes it stuck
swaying people can't see if it's not
that much I don't think is too far from
like Joe was saying so don't weigh from
other houses in the in the village your
doings that far away
I think the probably isn't Eva local
housing in here so saw each other what
going gates to your recommendation will
go against obvious recommendation this
was Jim I think my so I'll explain the
section 106 local neva
no I just say I just explained the
section 106 needs amend if you move out
to section 106 local needs
section 106 agreement basically this
will be an open market they could build
it and then sell it to somebody with
outside the district the day after
so it basically if you want this to be a
local needs dwelling and then it's
advertised for local people in the
future it's only for 12 weeks but it
still gives the opportunity for local
people to put a bid in for it then you
should attach your section 106 if you
want this to be a local needs property
so we don't know mr. Griffin will move
there or not we don't we don't know do
we
along with 106 tie onto it because at
the end of the day yes we do is 10 I
think to explain that I think against
the rock mr. Nash could said again I
went a bit quick if we attach a panic
section 106 agreement to it it prevents
you we're going going to be onto the
open market is that right it does
prevent being open market I mean the
valuation with these types of properties
can be the open market anyway the whole
point about local need section 106 is is
basically when somebody comes to so that
they have to basically advertise it for
local persons first to make a bid on the
property so it entitles folk people for
the 12 weeks to submit an offer but the
valuation can be sometimes the same as
open market but at least it gives the
opportunity for local people to actually
bid for that property first before it's
actually sold outside the district or
outside the actual
cast bones are we having a committee
development rights I was just going to
come on to that somewhat yes I think
that was with a condition that would be
appropriate because this one the
Lasallian point is is a small
two-bedroom bungalow the wine the
application came in without the
technical support and information it was
clear it was an open need at some open
market property but now we've had the
explanation from the parish council
we've had the applicant agent and I
think cats the Harvey needs to be
command it because it explained the
situation clearly with the evidence of
the local needs and the four conditions
plus the physical confines of the
village I think it's a lot more clear a
lot more precise in what we're looking
at and I think you can argue that it's
definitely within the confines of the
the area of Donna skip and also it meets
the local needs and again to protect
that local needs I think we removed the
permitted development rights to ensure
it still the two-bedroom bungalow or
two-bedroom probably and also we need to
make sure we help the section 106
obligation that's on there so if we do
go against officers recommendation we
need to make sure that it's if we do
agree to approve it we only approve with
the section 106 obligation and if that
obligation is not met the the permission
is it forces the artifice or it's not
not approved what's the right price for
them is it
it's one of them you put forward sure if
you put this forward without to me I'm
going to love conditions but if you want
to put it without the session with six
and basically you know I'm not happy to
do announcer right them so I think we've
got the fly over the meat and cats the
she's like biggest of the set of the
actual conditions that would be touched
yep so recommendation will be obviously
time limit plans materials landscape and
due to the location the openings for the
river the PD writes
Eevee charging points bins water but and
then the section winners those materials
said me too yes i that was a material
consideration there jack
sorry so we've had a proposal from
councillor fielding and supported
seconded podcaster bonds that we
approved the application subject to the
conditions mentioned by joe the removal
permitted development and this section
106 obligation being attached to the
permission okay all those in favor
committee results to agree and approve
application 19 slash zero one eight two
for a few well a subject to the
construction wanted in addition with its
section 106 agreement
when you've requested to have a quick
five-minute breaks so what we still got
a few applications go so just like this
yep it's yet five minutes if we go back
before I took up what I don't know where
the clock is over there that's yeah that
boy eight o'clock while that clock waste
he's board member right the Wrights
moving swiftly on to the next item on
the agenda which is a 19 / 0 1 6 3 5 fu
out which is grasmere ship borrowed
price marcin cv 47 for planet
application for erection of a two-story
four-bedroom running with within
curtilage of powering house thank you
so he's like a within the physical
confines of prized master as indicated
by the dock black dot before you the
application is seeking permission for
the erection of the two-story for
patient attached toilet in the red line
boundary shown for you
the salt is proposed in the residential
garden a priori house just for
clarification this is priori hope it was
formerly known as grasmere and this is a
short railroad access will be attained
from Churchill Road if permission is
forthcoming I stand by the aerial shot
before you the village is character is
largely compact in form however the
surrounding development comprises a
variety of ad sizes and design I do
request you please take note of the
village form in your considerations
this is the growing floor plan of the
application and it shows the primary
house to the north that's the plan
obviously patio growing floor access
coming in from fiery as an existing
garage from bill to pottery house but
this is the red line boundary
application solid so first of all plans
which indicate the bedrooms and the
layout of the house elevations which is
proposing a two-story trail in with
natural stone finished reclaim roof
tiles and timber sash windows this plan
demonstrates the street scene of the two
neighboring properties so if you were
standing on shuttle Road looking
directly at the consolidation so
proposal there and there's a priori
house for me grasmere and they've been
dryer in to the south of it this is the
reflective street scene of it this is
the site itself ask the garage for
belonged to Priory house neighboring
dwelling to south and outbuildings a
garden to the at neighboring dwelling
this is the firehouse immediate adjacent
onion ownership of the applicant
once again forward a principle of a
Centauri house streets in view and
looking down at site is to your right
looking down structure road into the
village this is as you can see here
directly facing onto the twin into this
artfully application side there is dense
hedgerow but I was probably the best
shot I could go this is a measly offset
so there is some stone bungalows within
the city of the side behind the site so
you got the application site there
Priory house is
Terrace semi saps Harrison's behind
and then just to the north across the
site is this dwelling of reasonable size
the plumb before you here shows a very
visible is plays of the application at
the minute and the reason I bring this
up is the application can achieve the
visibility space because grasmere is in
ownership of the applicant a condition
will be imposed if permission is
forthcoming to ensure these villages
plays are achieved however the highways
floors have requested section 106 is
agreed if guardsmen are sold in the
future the visible phase will have to be
maintained while future prizes of
dwelling this has been agreed by the
African therefore in consideration the
areas development plan national policy
and guidance and the relevant statutory
consultations the officers
recommendation is on planning bonds for
free will subject to the section 106 and
all parties confirmation regarding male
6 there are no updates here thank you
thank you Joe coming up our first
speaker please which is councillor Nick
Crawford from price master parish
council you just surprised master net
sorry caster forward you've got three
minutes would you like a warning with 30
seconds are you okay why not yeah so
good evening my name is Nick Fulford and
I'm chairman of price Martin parish
council we are objecting to this
development for a number of reasons
proposed houses we believe too large for
the plot this use for today campaign to
protect rural England who say that the
footprint is larger than those in the
vicinity we cannot tell from the
evidence of the submitted plans whether
or not that would be a suitable addition
to the area but if in size and bulk it
would not be then no doubt you were in
the lights of policies see us agency s9
this application there well it's not
mine in RT the scale of the property
would also be overbearing in relation to
the retirement bungalows opposite and
there is a significant privacy issue we
believe with six windows overlooking the
next door property old-world furthermore
the parish has no need for more for bed
houses the call strategy policy cf-19
suggests that fifteen to twenty percent
of market houses should be 4 + 4 +
bedroom properties while 40 to 45
percent should be 3 bed in priors
Marsten the village survey that formed
the basis of the recently adopted page
plan reported that we already had 51% -
4 + bedroom houses and only 30% of 3 bed
that's more than double the amount of 5
of 4 bed houses suggested by the core
strategy so there is a serious imbalance
in this village not surprisingly this
imbalance is reflected by the housing
needs survey also supported by the
Pirates plan that shows a need for 2 and
3 bed houses and not 4 and more bed
houses the Parish Council is not opposed
to development per se however we would
ask that the plans of developers are in
seat with the requirements of the parish
and that planet supporters in this in
other words we welcome proposals for two
and three-bedroom houses as opposed to
more 4-bedroom houses and larger open
spaces are an important part of the
character of village and this infill
further reduces the open space in
contradiction and the recently adopted
part which highlights their importance
furthermore the mock Georgian design is
inappropriate we believe and not in
keeping with the architecture of this
village you've already touched on that
visibility splay but also there is no
pavement - running along this part of
the road and a family house of this size
would be in danger for children walking
to and from
school buses office of the school itself
in summary we opposed the application a
house of this size and design and would
ask the committee to support our
objection on these grounds thank you
because we're in time right to any
questions from our cancer they proposal
is sustained and to that extent we have
no problems of that in fact we would ask
for that it's not the materials as the
size right no no sir
both would the offer yeah thank you
thank you
right
I know mr. Keith Harvey mr. Harvey you
got three minutes and again would you
like a warning with about 30 seconds or
are you okay I set the button in the
middle and the red light took three
minutes mr. Harvey thank you my wife and
I are the proprietors of this button
also the owners of the neighboring
property for me then discussed measures
now part accounts we first started
developing property over 30 years ago my
wife attended genuine passion for design
and all matters property related
recently our son has started to take
over the reins of our life is never far
away keeping a keen eye on design but
also something and scraping TV each
aspect of the developments to be
completed to a satisfaction historically
if you can be called locals I think we
probably are moved to Neptune in 1983
and 211 tonight's dings Parliament was
passed in about seven years ago we live
about a quarter of a mile from the plot
and have no intention of leaving so
getting the design of this property
right goes way beyond the bottom line we
socialized in the village of tender
local pub and generally try and get up
with everyone we do not want to lose
this when we first decide to develop the
moving properly the project seemed
daunting it has clearly not been touched
decades preparing the pace just about
everything including reinforcing the
foundations if that's not enough my wife
and son following footsteps would never
use new
when old could be fair however what's a
private house made now the picture it's
value will drop like a stone if we do
not do an equally good job next door but
I appreciate that you cannot please all
the people all the time and I'd like to
say a few words about the Egyptians and
the possibility of building on this pot
occurred to us the first thing we did
was to contact highlights they were very
helpful and where their input we asked
Joe Allen to give us some thoughts on
sketches that we prepared it was also
very helpful but suggestion that we talk
to the neighbors and the parish council
this we did the tables were positive and
unfortunately the parish council would
not see us until we had launched a full
application genuinely wanted their input
and would have listened carefully to
their comments but by the time they saw
the plans it was very difficult to
accommodate all of their ideas that
effectively starting again another issue
that was raised is parking but I have a
careful examination of the panel show
that each plot has ample on-site parking
I think I'm now out of time but the
truly deliberate I hope you'll spend a
moment or two looking at the five
photographs that Jared produced we've
provided a private house shown before
and after with your approval we have to
do something very similar on this plot
Thank You mr. Hawley any questions
catch the bombs council said it was a
big over for the plot that plan there I
assumed their houses in the middle and
what is the brand baton that's the
that's the frontage of the property and
the frontage of the property next door
which comprises of the upper property I
like our house the other property that's
been referred to which was shown in the
pictures and you'll see through its eyes
shown in the picture
the bulk of it if you like and you're
going to end up with something it's very
similar next door
pirate houses in fact five bedrooms the
new property for pootis fall won't be
close to the walls of the Union
properties I've got a question for you
mr. Harvey the first console mentioned
lack of a footpath the traffic give me
some indication of how much traffic
obviously you said you live nearby how
much traffic goes down there and please
the chopping going to Pryor's baths and
is never going to be particularly great
because it's Pryor's Marsten and you
tend to get the prize marks and if you
want to go the prize faster and my
acceptance note pavement there that
affects all of the properties down that
side of the street to the entire house
and including the neighboring property
with the hedges that was shown on the
screen it's not something that's been a
concern as far as I know and it's not
something that I would think needed to
be catered for as it would basically
create a very large footpaths for a very
small football okay thank you Catherine
in the area there is some street
lighting I have to say that Street
Lightning lighting in price of arson is
not wonderful and but I wouldn't be
advocating more street lighting because
to a certain extent in answer to the
challenge of illegitimate
you would be able to see your way in
that area again it's not there's no
lighting in the village is that you can
see you know we possibly take away some
of the charm so there's no truth that
you walk back from the pub takes you
slightly longer than the walk to the
book thank you it's a lighting good
enough for traffic oncoming traffic to
see you actually walking along do you
say it's sufficient but is it today it's
not a hazard for traffic going through
it yeah I think I think we'll I think
yes irrespective whether there's another
house that the lighter won't change so
Jim it's a four-bedroom house is it any
bigger than next door is a Priory house
there was that bigger in
it's bigger than prior house or not as
big as for Italy fine thank you
not mr. Harvey thank you very much
you're free to go thank you all right
stencil are up can you come forward
please ignore them cancer you have five
minutes when you're ready to start thank
you very much as you've heard from the
Parish Council the prize Mastan housing
needs survey call for two and
three-bedroom houses not four-bedroom
houses
this finding be incorporated into the
2019 parish plan adopted only months ago
as a district council we encourage
communities produce these surveys we
represent a lot of work and I feel we
duty bound to keep awake to their
outcome the emerging site allocations
plan recognizes its secondary school
prices are a problem in the south and
flat front area including a moratorium
including poet prize master and parish
council of Bob Stevens a governor of
South and College reported to me this
week that the college is under pressure
now facing many appeals for places
therefore we should be building only for
objectively determined local needs not
importing extra precious Joe's
projecting the map there a parish plat
map is replicated in the parish plan and
I'll see the the office was used a
formula which is district garden white
guidance for the size of the plot
include in the in minute amenity space
and concludes that the officer the
officer concluded dwelling is not
oversized for the plot obviously I
respect his view but after discussion
with planning and policy officers I come
to a different conclusion that we should
be looking at the guidance for the
character of
settlement and the fall of development
within the village even for smaller
homes it is a pattern of detached houses
probably a bit small that actually
detached house has been set in a less
congested manner on the plots which i
think is the guidance we should be using
you probably can't see that actually
it's not clear to me how the parking
standards ought to be met in his Justice
space which is bounded by a wall these
spaces were not delimited on the plans
which we've just seen the supplementary
planning guidance calls for five will at
least five space this is a five bedroom
house next door across both shared areas
which at the moment in the shared
ownership of the applicants County
highways as we heard from the officers
objected to the vision display because
it relied on vision over that
neighboring property only withdrawing
their objection because of the offer to
secure a legal agreement to prevent this
obstruction I have to say if we're going
to rely on a legal action between
neighbors to keep views clear in the
interest of safety should that other
property be sold that doesn't seem quite
right to me could I have the photograph
please zoom the main difficulty I have
with this application is the overbearing
impact on the retirement bungalows
opposite which have been sensitively
designed to accord with the right local
vernacular being set to the east of the
proposed dwelling these bungalows will
suffer a lot of loss of light especially
in the late autumn and winter afternoons
because of the long reach high parallel
to the road on the new Dolan opposite
and the existing dwelling adjacent could
we have the street st. Joe that you've
already shown us cannot pause while Joe
gets that
it was a drawing joke you got the
drawing of the two properties that's it
yeah so those bungalows
don't back up one those bungalows are
our opposite the combination of those
two properties on the right as far as I
can see this semi slab fronted design is
not in keeping with the rest of the
conservation area I believe this design
would have a negative effect on the
street scene and detract from the
character of the conservation area in
summary and in the context of the
village and street scene I conclude the
proposed Romy's excessively size for the
plot we have an overbearing and blocking
effect on the retirement bungalows
opposite in an apparent bulk and mass
and the semi fronted design semi slab
fronted design is out of character with
the rodent village as expressed in the
recently adopted parish plan I believe
the application should be refused on the
basis it does not conform with cs5
section B within the conservation area c
s9 section b is ten bullet point one and
two and supplementary planning document
letter D pages three and four and letter
O which is a parking standards if the
committee on the other hand is minded to
grant I ask that you apply condition for
the construction plan including the
parking issues has been in the past if
they were on there they'd fill up the
entire right hand side that blank space
they go for the top of the bottom that
page I think Joe's probably got a
picture
okay there's equivalent but there is of
a bungalows if you go I've got
additional slides so you can see there
I'm going to write on side and there you
go there is a set of bongos run a
directly opposite as well
so you're right yeah that's the picture
you want strike chain will cut onto the
counter balance question here you can so
you you can see sort of all all the
properties that are close together sort
of exactly opposite the application side
any further questions
No thank you can stir up free to go
right we've gone to fishness for the
officers now you can stir fielding do we
know the size the area of that the plot
that I wanting to develop and how much
bigger or smaller is it than the
neighboring one sure
so for one thing I'd say you can see
there I represent it is on tonight
member of the overall development is
[Music]
pauses I can't give you a absolute
figure got the couple of questions
I think catch the rap was saying that
you'd applied guidance on the size of
the plot on the density that was one for
the general point of Stratford district
as opposed to the one that should be
specific for prize master there's a few
elements that assessment so first off
there is guidance estates in the
neighborhood mean is that where it meets
the requirements of private meaning
spades to the rear and in this case some
area to saw United Stated room the area
that there is sufficient mean Streisand
there in a Vietnamese yeah
secondly and as I've stated in the
report I've had to also done my
assessment on the surrounding areas yes
I agree there is definitely adventure
unit here of small bungalows but you've
got pottery house which is quite a large
open area you've also got the name and
railings and so which is quite an
intense plot with a large area and also
the Holloway is there and then you've
got the listed buildings and the orchids
and so forth from the vicarage and a lot
so we have they do a whole assessment on
the character of the area so it meets
all neighbor and emini columns for
future offers and at the same time in my
opinion when during my assessment there
is sufficient evidence of large scale
plots and then saris of dwellings within
the vicinity of the area so the
requirements and then she can yes
you're going to do that for neighbor and
mean it is that shows the plot is
sufficient on that size for few chop
pyres and then also under the SPD
requirements you try and make sure it
fits in with the locality through
orientation they are scaled so so forth
and even with saris I think that plan
represents a request for additional
information trying to make sure it
wasn't overdone there and made in
dwellings custom Upson thanks Michelle
again that may be a Costa Mesa parish
plan how much weight does this cook it's
a material consideration but because the
Paris plan doesn't go for examination it
doesn't cover a full way it's just
material acceleration so fundamentally
unlock your neighborhood plan that goes
through an examination and then
referendum by an examiner pointed by
secretaries by an independent examiner
for a lot of sexually today it never
goes for that examination so the Pirates
put it together and you use until
consideration it doesn't carry full
weight insemination patients right so
the questions to do with the parking
there is sufficient parking I completely
and somewhere there more members come
from that it's not predictive on the
plan but as you can see before you there
is sufficient parking to accommodate the
size free off-road parking spaces I
stated with my report and also the
maneuvering turning in and I wasn't
initially raised by highways
all right everybody happy now right
swing move on to the divine name of them
peace who wants to start on this one is
that confused yeah completely confused
thanks for sure yeah okay
my look to this scientist thought oh
yeah because the large houses a lot of
large houses implies Mastan with another
arch house be perhaps I'll I think it
was was fit in with the with the street
scene but if we did recommend for
approval um I must say we must go for
natural stone as in that's my stipulate
there could be natural stone because we
caught a cold before question so they
submit some kills and at the same time
and the council procedures we can salt
without discharge if it was approved
with the Paris Congress also as a local
authority and the practical come to an
agreement modernly naturist oh yeah and
as I see that with a bit concern about
overloading in a local school but I
think even with a smaller house had ever
seen amount of children I think it's yes
mine South in college oh okay
attend these streetlights comes in comp
no Street Lighting's and at all so
anyway mr. chairman I'm unfortunately
I'm 44
no Idol rock but I support the office
recommendation on this is Jim thank you
thank you I wasn't this way
sorry for interrupting that's all
canceling a second counselor Mills is
comments on it it's it's it's large but
on the other hand there are a lot of
large there's a number of large houses
in the village also they've got
bungalows opposite which are therefore
don't which are done sizable for people
who wanted a second you Seraphin yeah I
do have an issue been in the building
trade more my life that it looks as
though to me it's over development needs
to fill in the bottom perhaps a
three-bedroom house would be more time
as George Kabri said once the house
should take up no more than a quarter of
the land Thank You Annie any further
comments sympathy for the parish council
and the ward member on this one on um
slightly unbalanced on this one again I
think he's quite a big property and it's
not concerns about the overbearing
nature on the other properties but I
don't think we need to to go to the back
we've had a proposal by cancer bonds and
seconded by Councillor for a joke and I
just very similar sorry you guys I know
we're similar
the visibility study itself it's a time
but just clarifying members that the
county have requested the section 106
agreement to make sure the visibility
spy stays in place but at the moment I
don't know whether it should be tied in
with the actual planning application or
it should be a separate application but
whatever it is that you are undertaking
or section 106 screaming should come
before the planning application or
Planning Commission but I don't know
whether the county would wanted this to
be party or whether they can actually be
party with the owner themselves so
there's a bit of clarification needed
you know to get it through so to be
confirmed please chair yeah and do I
have to come back to me if you wish yep
I think come back here to come back to
turn just find a clarification there
seems to be a mood in the room for
having reference for stone should you go
to to approval on this would you like us
to add that as an informative so there's
a clear indication to to the applicant
in the event of an approval natural
stone yeah okay
so we've had proposal on the second on
this one by Kessler
okay we're just clarifying that so we
funded proposal on the second day to
grant this application and we'll go to
the vote subject again to the section
106 condition and obligation and it
coming back if we agreed to grant this
coming back to me with final for a final
approval right all those in favor of
granting this application against
committee resolves to grant application
19 - 0 1 6 3 5 /f you are thank you
our next item on the agenda will be 19
slash zero one seven one nine ful Lum
next to an 88 main foot clothes was born
direction of two-bedroom Anglo access
and parking and our case mr. chairman
yeah just just there was two seconds for
the prior will for the group of that as
well but I'm sure she enjoys this into
you as well can serve answer as well
well worth the admission for your life
so presented officer is mister for
Thompson please thank you sure Thank You
counselors my apologies to the counselor
for keeping anything so long and we are
back in Wells one in the northeastern
part which is the amount that closed the
state the application site is narrow
plot of land which I understand was
fully part of the garden 290 Mountford
close which is this property on the
corner you'll note from this that this
degree of variation in the plan form of
the properties but most of them fill
their their frontages here is the site
plan we've got an amendment to the
originally submitted plans which just
shifted the front elevation back very
slightly by about 1.5 meters just to
bring it in line with the neighboring
properties these blue lines here are
angles taken from number 90 just to show
at the 45 and 25 degree rules which
we'll come back to you like two-car
parking spaces at the front which
exceeds our requirements and meets the
requirements of neighborhood plan policy
WW 10 not 9 as I've said repeatedly in
my report for some reason and also I've
got a mention of WW 12 in my report that
should be 13 strange mental block with
the neighborhood plan policies
there's cycle no cycle parking indicated
which would be a requirement
there is plenty of space to the rear for
that
here are the elevations this is the
proposed bungalow in the center rich
height midway between the bungalow 88
mount foreclose two-story house number
90 on the corner it's a transitional
character it would be sort of towards
the entrance and the exit of the estate
and unusually for Mountford close the
gable end will be facing the highway and
as I said in my report it's unusual but
not unique and there are several other
houses on this state we'll see a couple
of them in a second here is the site
itself it's not a lot to look at just
grass down with closed border fencing no
trees to speak of there is a small bit
of hedging towards the front of the site
here there you'll see number 90 and
faces the corner of the junction and his
gable end onto it equally here number 86
his gable end onto the road that's
that's pretty much to say apart from we
do have a previous refusal on the site
that was for an outline planning
permission I've taken the opposing view
here largely because all we had with the
with the outline application was
indicative plans with this we have the
detail in my judgment the harm that we
feared for the outline stage doesn't
hasn't materialized here that is a
judgment call which obviously you may
come to a different conclusion and I've
also taken into account the our policy
CS 19 and they
plant policy for we w8 I hope it still
be w-wait which call for to bed bomb
blows they're primarily to do with
affordable housing but nevertheless it
indicates a level of demand for this
type of housing yeah that's that's the
application oh thank you for pointing
out the numbering areas and getting a
lot to apologize to the parish council
for that so please take that on board
and can we have our first speaker which
is cancer prior three minutes far away
thank you test prong cancellous thank
you the price council objects is
planning application on a number of
grounds firstly mount foreclose is one
of our most congested roads between the
hours of 8 a.m. and 9:30 a.m. and 2 p.m.
and 5 p.m. with further extensive use of
the school building in the evenings and
weekends
the school has no provision for Vista
parking which leads to congested parking
on the roadway and the pavements around
the whole area the close has a suggested
driving route in an anti-clockwise
direction during these hours this
proposed development is almost
immediately after you turn into
Mountford closed going in a clockwise
direction round a blind Bend the
development offers no turning circle on
the site of this instead any occupier
would have to either reverse into the
parking spaces or reverse out neither
option despite the offices suggestion is
safe given the level of visibility and
the congestion on the road
secondly the site is very small you can
see the size from the report 9 pound 5
meters at the front narrowing to 9
meters and back the houses on Mount for
clothes have spacious plots with good
personal space at the front as well as
surrounding gardens and this will have
neither also the houses and
and I disagree with the officer in this
case predominately facing to the close
actually walk grounded to this evening
before I came and there are very few the
gable ends tend to be parts of larger
bungalow Civic a blend plus the front
door next to it so there are very few
properties that are aligned in the
direction of this food was proposed to
be the roof line of the proposed
development is not in tune with the
bungalow next to it at 88 and to
describe this being a transitional
appearance I think is stretching it a
bit far really the parish council whilst
agreeing that there is a need for
bungalows in the village and it was
mostly for affordable housing do not
agree with this development did not
agree with this development answers that
need in a satisfactory way given the
size of the plot its surroundings and
the potential for further congestion in
an already congested area so we would
ask that committee rejects this
application on those grounds that's the
prime any questions
hence the vans but you see we're
concerned about parking highways and
objectively know they have the obviously
don't come round the close to look at it
when the traffic's all there okay I
would add actually to your question we
have a huge police presence around the
close because of the problems of parking
just can be a bit more combative cancer
and bit more understanding that the
street scene really obviously Wilson
you've mentioned about the gable end
being the rarity and been attached
normally to a bigger bomb glow okay just
give me a little my spell out please
well I said I walked round today and
it's a mixture of two storey houses and
bungalows and bunglers that have had a
sort of a half a beat I did on the back
of them so there's quite a number of
houses that are shaped like number 88
that you can see on this slide now with
a slight gable the front door but the
bungalow is facing out onto the road and
that's true apart from one in the far
corner which is set
the same angle as this particular
bungalow is but that's the only one but
set with no front door along the
frontage of the house it's down the side
of the house I said some of the bunglers
are very large and they're very sort of
they have lots of bits to them but they
all face onto the road
thank you very much more or less more
question chairman apart from does the
neighborhood plan have anything to say
about councillor Crompton question about
the layout and design of plots that
night
additionally inform was about that
street scene the neighborhood plan says
that we would look for developments to
be sensitive to the area in which
they're placed and this one is not
sensitive to the area in which it is
placed I was just this pot here
it just seemed quite cramped front from
from what we can see on the using this I
think this is quite part of them 19 what
was this area of land was there any
designation of this land or anything
could in the plan seventies back garden
yep okay no that's that's okay I'm just
can't surprise you're you're free to go
thank you very much okay thank you our
next speaker is mr. Leslie Greenwood mr.
Greenwood I'm sure you know the bond by
now three minutes well we'll give you
the shadley chairman thank you put to
the officers for a consideration on this
one
it's a proposed to pet bungalow 72
square metres to give you an idea of the
scale in comparison to the darlings got
one which was 84 square metres as we've
heard everybody thinks there should be
bungalows built in wells born but as
you've seen in the previous application
tonight four wells born 417 two-story
houses they often don't get built
opportunities come along on sites like
this that are somewhat constrained and
bungalows are the perfect solution for
them so it's an infill site a vacant
site in the northern part of the village
where potential once infill and I do
have to take some issue as far as I'm
aware this hasn't for many years been
anybody's back garden if we supplied the
1960s or in a survey plan with the
application which showed it as being a
separate plot of land it's been a vacant
site for quite a long time in any case
it may have been about garden at one
time but the only survey plan suggests
not it's a bespoke design to fit
discreetly on to this site modest scale
modest height steps up in the streets
it would occupy I just did a quick
figure about 30 percent of the plot or
possibly a bit less bungalows don't
normally want to have large corns
attached to them because if they're
designed for elderly people or people
with mobility difficulties they don't
want a lot of upkeep the character of
the area's is quite varied it's in 1950s
1960s some 1970s I think straight with
bungalows and houses different designs
variety is part of the character it's
not an area that is uniform in its
design we say this will fit in perfectly
discreetly and unobtrusively it's not
something that you would notice once
it's built as being in any way out of
character it was designed also with the
neighbors in mind not to be overbearing
or overshadowing to them and it's the
council's tests there'll be no
overlooking windows
I think the Highways officers must be
aware of the traffic issues around the
score or mouth for close it's a
long-standing thing that there is
traffic there as there is a lot around
most schools they haven't raised any
technical objection visibility is
perfectly adequate for the speeds of
traffic 15 centons
just to finish off if you look at a
photo of the site now it's got a closed
boarded fence across the front it's not
an attractive addition to the street
scene if you allow a bungalow here it
will meet a definite need for bungalows
and it will actually enhance the site
thank you very much mr. bright questions
to the agent catch the rock unconcerned
ups
to the pictures as a bungalow you know
from what I can recall of this street
scene that the angle of the roofs the
the pitch of the roof is some quite
shallow in most of the bungalows that
this one seemed to have quite a steep
pitch roof why is that and why was it
not made shallower and because I clearly
that's going to be one of the issues
isn't it impact on the street things
seems a bit out of character it's really
comment you can offer on that when
you've said it you feel it fits in with
the street seems you very I haven't done
a survey of the roof pitches on all the
properties in the street scene but like
with most of the characteristics of now
proposed they vary and some or I would
say are very similar to this we gauge
the pitch so that it would as you can
see step up from the Lord I'm going to
the right to the two-story house on the
Left we talked to the planning officer
about this during the application
because we knew were getting objections
and suggested that we could lower the
ridge line if that was necessary in
order to get support but the officers
were happy with the way this presented
in the street scene and we agree that
this is a good solution the public
clarification from the officer but the
is it has it been I mean does this fill
the whole of the site this bungalow it's
the only you say that people don't want
a large garden these days well must have
some sort of garden and that looks a bit
squeezed into me there and I'm on a site
you do you know who owns these plots it
next door I decide okay well there's two
questions yes I answer both of them
first on on the ownership he's owned by
the applicant
is a local local developer who lives in
Wales born in terms of God's eyes hit
more than meets the council standard for
a two-bedroom property and as I said it
is a small smallish bungalow and the if
you work out the size of the plot which
is about 28 meters by about nine to nine
and a half meters wide and you you
checked the size of the floor space of
72 square meters then it doesn't occupy
more than 30% of the plot thank you no
further questions
right Thank You mr. green I want for you
to go right points of clarification the
officer okay some Elms yes thank you
just the size of this I mean what what
what's the distance between the the
fence there and the bungalow itself
I can concerning to confirm what mr.
Greenwood said there the rear garden and
exceeds by some margin standards that we
set in our requirements SPD for a
two-bed bungalow the distance that the
back isn't enormous and I'm sorry for
you but the dwelling it backs onto is
quite a distance away so the separation
distances still still work again in
accordance with our standards and either
side I take it aren't any windows in the
bungalow on the on the side that face
onto the fences any windows on the side
elevation to ground-floor only said they
would look on to the fence essentially
mr. fielding concerned at the pitch of
the roof of that building because we've
had some in one of my parish got a
question where the owner has now gotten
put on another floor in are we going to
take away the development right to to
this side to prevent somebody coming
along and putting another flooring and
but don't think there would be
sufficient space for them to do that
furthermore any because of the
orientation of the plot it might not it
might cause some comment in the street
scene what it does mean is that any dorm
is gonna be on the side elevation which
means they'd have to be obscurely glazed
anyway even if they did decide to go
ahead and do that which as I said I
don't believe there's enough room in
that roof to get an extra story yeah one
thing rules concerns me about parking in
front of a property and I've seen this
many times that people tend to back out
they don't back in whereas some years
ago there was always that you had space
to turn round in the front of your
property I've seen too many people
reverse saved onto roads that's that's
annoyed
[Music]
yeah you want to give some clarification
on the parking pool yeah I mean the
there is you correct there's no turning
space on site I've taken the view that
highways haven't objected we can't
really condition but hey you're going
away even if there is turning space on
site we can't we can't impose any
condition that forces people to use it
and so I have given them given the
context I've taken the context and the
lack of a highways objection I should
say I've taken the view that the parking
provision is sufficient to avoid any
impact on highway safety or congestion
will there be provision for two parking
spaces there you've got some green space
that could easily be added into the
parking it or the driveway and would
that be possible on the application is I
don't see any reason why not counselor
anything is it's not part of the
application is it come apart by this is
an urban area wouldn't normally ask for
returning had to be included on on a
driveway in this position and this is in
this type of location these are low low
speed areas and this parking arrangement
where you reverse I do have a signal
with this out is it's fairly standard
arrangement right should we move on to
the Divine Anam Cara Nelson nice miss
Jimmy yeah I'm you know wait again look
at these sites and it is I can't say I'm
that happy with I mean it's you need to
be crammed in cars have reversing or out
but I can't think the good any reason to
object to it and I can't say I'm happy
with it
it is right opposite the school in just
cram it in Oh God again I can't think
any good planning reason to turn it down
so I have to give the obvious
recommendation on this machine the bonds
[Music]
below is full on the plots I did go and
have a look
bungalow next door to story as next door
down the road so it's a mixture of
houses in the road and far as I can see
I can't see any planning reason for
refusal so I'm quite happy to second
[Music]
instead but I think personally think I
don't know if into the design I don't
think it fits in with the street scene
in that area from what I recollect of
this street I think the bridge is the
wrong angle I think it's too overbearing
in the plot on the other hand I don't
think there's sufficient strength you
know there no front door in there and
this think sufficient strength to refuse
it but what I would say as it's so
congested in there I think it would be
difficult to put any further development
like sheds and stuff in there with I
think the points been made PD I think
would give them capacity unless I'm
corrected by the officers to put a room
in the roof and I don't think we want
that so I believe there's sufficient
grounds to remove PD rights from this
development I also note in respect to
Peters question about the no highways
haven't objected but I noticed on the
landscaping
presentation there we've got some bushes
right next to where you would reverse
out in a vehicle so I think I would like
to see a landscaping condition at the
front that prevents any growth being put
in the way that might obscure driving
out of the out of the way so I would go
along I think reluctantly with approval
of this application subject to removal
of PD rights and a landscaping condition
that stopped it interfering with the
business place development I can't see
any merits in the design also worries me
it just stops it it's the school
mother's with prams etc and it does need
to have better visibility or even a
turning circle in the in the confines of
the property because of the basically
the danger of people backing out at
school time and other times
I could think of a list of reasons not
to like it but I can't think of a reason
a planning reason to refuse it so whilst
we may not like it and we may have to go
along with the officers recommendations
I just say where I'm on this one
definitely don't like this one I think
it squeezed in I would object on this I
wouldn't go along with the officers
recommendation on this one I think there
is sufficient reason they said to keep
him with a street scene didn't refer to
the local character it's juic
potentially overbearing and for example
what the game will end again it was
mentioned that it's not in keeping with
local street scene
whilst our sympathy for the parish
council Ong the high-rise issues I think
we are very limited what we can say
about the highways and been reined by
the schools we know which light but were
they too firm steer from the Highways
Authority I can't see any reason what we
can or I could object on highways issues
so my my objection would be it squeezed
in not in keeping with local character
it's the next case that once said if
it's not right if it's not quite right
it's wrong and I don't think it's in
keeping so here officer I think I'm out
of keeping with the rest of the
committee but I thought old same or you
and I think I need you to say this so
but no I'm asking that you know it's
people is on on the bus so that's that's
my I don't want to be seen as leading
the community but that's only to give my
me know relax this do they so that's the
rock German I think we're all at the
same mind and I think the rest of it was
struggling to find reasons to refuse it
but I think you may have swayed my view
which was I didn't like it but I
couldn't see the reasons to refuse it
but I think you've generated you vote
got some reasons to refuse it which I
think I would go along with those
reasons you've stages refused it because
you've put into him into contrast what
what those are I was going to ask if we
could do something about the regional
but I mean obviously that's redesigning
it isn't it so I would tend to agree
with what you've said so I I think I've
changed my position I think I would go
along with refusal for the reasons you
just stated clearly there is a precedent
we turned on down in a similar squeezed
in property up on the counter
opposite the old step doctor surgery
last year and quite honestly it's
exactly the same it's too tight it's and
you can't really take any machinery or
anything down the side of the building I
just don't like it which is not a good
planning reason we had a proposal to
accept this do we have a seconder for
that so with the proposal to accept it
again
so we did originally have a proposal on
a second heir to grant this and but can
you just confirm for the Miss Gemma I
withdraw my that okay
so catch the Barnes you've know
indicated you put parties to accept the
officers recommendation to grant is that
right but no it's not what I like is how
a seconder to cancel advances proposal
to cramp the application no I don't get
out
we now need as an alternative proposal
cancel failure could you put your
machine on please I'm happy to think
it's Justine on line I come at which
it's not in keeping it's too overbearing
oversight it there is yes do you want to
committee of the reasons sorry in
relation to the reason we piece up in
2015
I read you the refusal reason at that
time it was receives bear in mind that
this was an outline so there were no
details of their development the site
forms a narrow strip of land enclosed on
all sides between neighboring
residential development dis
characterized by reasonably large
detached dwellings set within
proportionately large plots the
utilization of the uncharacteristically
narrow application site to accommodate
the construction of a single dwelling
will be wholly out of keeping and
disruptive to the space
had pattern of development in the area
this would be visually harmful to the
character and appearance of the street
scene now that was a fairly open-ended
reason for refusal would you like to
narrow that that down to the specifics
of this application because there's a
good reason for refusing it again I
would go along with them but there there
could be some strengths through 15 and
with regards to our two keeping and too
overbearing for the plot cs5 Section B
0.1 scale gives a location visual
impacts on the local landscape or
townscape
so just for clarification do you wish to
keep that first part of that reason for
would you wish to keep that part of the
reason for refusal which is a character
street scene and character reason
refusal okay the development the second
stage could then be in relation to the
design design and design height scale
ding conflict would be in conflict with
the with the intentions of CFCs 9 and in
doing so would result in an
uncharacteristic and disruptive
development within the appropriate
we need a second we're looking for a
seconder for this case the rock
right so we've had a proposal on a
second to refuse the application for the
reasons just mentioned and current and
this will clarify them just to make sure
100% clear on those will go to the vote
all those in favor of refusing this
application six children against
abstentions luncheon committee resolves
to refuse application 1901 seven one
nine ful right we've gone we've now gone
over the three hours and we've got one
application there so I'm asking approval
to carry on the one more item on the
agenda all those in favor
yeah carried and I will now pass on the
chair to catch the Mills
yep better you break them okay some
elves
[Applause]
the other thing myself
last but one matter on the agenda this
is for application number 19 oblique
zero one five seven eight bleep ful
Brooklyn's farm the demolition of
redundant traditional agricultural
structures conversion of remaining bound
to dwelling a healthy erection of two
new dwelling houses it's the poor show
Thank You councillor Mills I shall try
and keep this brief application site
here is on the southwestern corner of
Southam tesco is about there in the
industrial estate and this application
site is a black dot it is a farm and
small holding with some converted barns
here where my pointer is one of which is
the belongs to the applicant these green
circles here are trees protected by tree
preservation order these are public
rights-of-way which aren't affected by
the by the proposal some distance to the
north is the zone of restraint and the
Holywell is up in that direction access
is down here onto the a 435 this is the
existing buildings in plan form these
are barns here this barn here is largely
to be retained and converted here is the
access and we can perhaps a little look
these are the existing buildings has
corrugated steel sheds protected trees
to the left of the image underneath my
feet as the photo is taken here is the
concrete access track leads down to the
road here is the barn to be retained the
central element there is that is a
primary part a lot of this is to be the
corrugated steel will be removed
of course here it is from the other
angle and you can just see to the left
of the image there is this shed which is
also to be retained as guruji you'll be
excited to learn
we have full video to pay you just to
give you just just to show off how
technically advanced we are and give you
a bit of an idea of the layout of the
site the large building in the centre
will be demolished in its entirety I see
at the land to the north here that's yep
that's to be demolished there trees over
to the right and we're heading steadily
towards the houses on Newsted drive all
close got this wrong earlier drive thank
you and number one to the right of the
image number three to the left helps to
be tall sometimes and here we can just
see
a concrete truck leading through the
site and as we can see the buildings are
currently in uses storage and I think
that's all suffice
right another photo of the open land the
north there's a couple of fruit trees in
the center which will be removed as part
of the application and one must photo
right now on to the good part this is
the scheme that came in excuse me for a
second
last year was withdrawn earlier this
year it was similar in terms of the
amount of development proposed the only
difference was that the two new
dwellings which you can see up here were
rather taller and bulkier and had what
my colleague described as awkward and
contrived fenestration which is to say
weird windows and doors there were other
concerns about the access specifically
its ability to accommodate the refuse
collection vehicles the serve the
district there were primary concerns
over the impact of these large dwelling
houses on numbers 1 and 3 new stairs to
drive this is the elevation that we're
really interested in this is as it would
be seen from nice to drive in a bit more
detail you can see a large gable end and
a blank elevation there that's the
retain building which wouldn't wouldn't
change this is the new proposal that
we're looking at tonight this is the
access what you can see here this orange
section is a BIM collection point which
obviates the need for refuse collection
vehicles to enter the site it is a very
long way from the dwelling houses we
normally specify about 25 metres as a
maximum carry distance for citizens to
take their bins to the collection point
this would be about 125 but what that
does mean is that a the access becomes a
lot safer because bin lorries don't have
to try and get into it B which you let's
see on this one these trees here will be
protected the original proposal had the
access coming straight through and the
route protection areas here now because
it doesn't have to accommodate the
refuse collection vehicles we can follow
the line of the existing concrete track
and then keep it out of the route
protection area and that way is as you
can see the there's a courtyard here
with visitor parking spaces whose garage
which meets our standards at least with
the external cycle and the storage you
can see between there we've got a
condition to secure that the joins in
plan form they're not substantially
different to the previous proposal in
terms of the floor space they provide
but as you see from the elevations there
are a lot lower so this is this here is
the same elevation that I showed you on
the previous set of plans you'll see
that the new dwelling is in fact
slightly lower than the existing
building over here the additional floor
space is provided through dormers in the
roof so they are one point five storey
dwelling effectively this window here we
have a condition to make that make sure
that's obscurely glazed
these are also side elevations so any
new windows that are put in would have
to also be obscurely glazed by national
law and fixed shut so there shouldn't be
any impact on on privacy there that
is yeah that is this one and that is the
the proposal thank thank you for there's
nobody from Tunnel parish council here
first speakers of the objectors is Dave
and Mary Upton neighbors this mister
dismissed Upton wait wait for it okay
three minutes we will you be just
between the two of you or just one of
you just me I'm just okay client got
three minutes
thank you okay if he could give me a 30
second okay right my name is Dave Upton
my wife Mary where I am lifelong
resident of Southam
I live at number three Newsted and drive
and I'm also speaking on behalf of my
neighbors mr. and mrs. Malins and number
one now
I understand that so some District
Council of objected to this and they are
very familiar with the facility the area
so I think they're beaut a consideration
I'm a little disappointed that our
parish council can't speak on this
occasion I understand the reasons why I
object to this proposal are three main
points the first point is that I
understand that the north side of this
is encroaching into the stove Valley
area and I understand this is an area
restraint and in fact it's the only
substantial green area going into south
on us remaining and I think it should be
looked at on this the second point is
that the proposal the design consists of
a large brick gable end being positioned
SMAC centrally at the end of my god now
I understand it's sixteen meters from my
house so it's outside the 30 meter
revelation but we spend 80 percent of
our time in the conservatory which is
actually less than 12 meters from this
built which is only one meter the other
side of the war now this will create
light it will create a massive shadow
over at garden we spend a lot of time in
the garden that's our main objection on
there the third objection is the road
access now it's one of the worst
junctions in South there are actually
five Road accesses within 50 yards of
this entrance
you've got the a45 you've got a watt it
Road you got Brooklyn's farms you've got
Hartley Gardens and you've also got
Newsted lodge nursing home as well as
it's one of the main pedestrian access
is pedestrians now there's been two
serious accidents I know of and they
have actually sent photographic
accidents photographic evidence of a
recent accident there that involved the
police ambulance fire everything going
on yeah we've got 30 seconds so as you
can see it is a dangerous Junction and
there has been another accident I am
aware of as well that's my own now with
the putting the bin collection right
there with vehicle stopping on that
junction and people have to wait up to
five times a normal recommended distance
to take their bins I'm not sure this is
a good idea
[Music]
also nobody's mentioned the bats
there's hundreds of bats there a fire
hydrant the late time thank you thank
you mr. Upton thank you questions mr.
Upton Kelso Locke Thank You chairman
good evening waiting for a long evening
and I could the officer get as a plan up
and then you could show us where the
pointer is then so which way is north
please yeah it's facing north thank you
very much thank you just you say you've
got concern of where the bins are going
to be put and and where the the big
collectors being made and I know I Drive
into this I hope that something
clarification Gottman careful they can't
get them the bins down there so they're
gonna park on the front drive right on
this Junction and it's the main incoming
road from Limington spa and there's lots
of traffic accidents there now
a lot of pedestrians as well going to
Tesco's because it's the main back
entrance thank you any more questions
that's it Thank You mr. Upton thank you
very much
it's a points of clarification for the
officer we know if there has been a back
survey done on the site yes there was
this mitigation measures proposed and
the count ecologist is happy we've got a
condition to secure those those measures
okay Thank You Nigel mr. Ward member not
speaking no could you remind as it
happen if I've missed it as what our
refuse collection team have said about
this it's obviously been revised in view
of their comments on the previous
arrangement both day and County highways
suggested having the bin plane to the
front of this side and are there not
some disability requirements who said it
was a hundred metres to take the bins
had they considered that do we know I
would assume so that it's again it's a
judgment call for councillors to make
how much how much respective weight to
give up all so just remember John so so
this the big collections at the end it's
about how far was it they've got to take
their bins from the furthest dwelling
about 125 metres John okay
on the plan you shown there
there's a sort of an area that goes in
off the drive halfway up the actual peak
what is that is that another house or is
that they the current farm house that is
Brooklyn's that's the applicants
dwelling so going further on up if we
may where is the one that is going to be
generated from the existing buildings is
that the first one you come to on the
right I'm indicating it with the points
in area it's the first one on the right
so that's that's the first one and and
where is the actual bit that still being
still old building rather than a bit
that's tying the two together that would
be the northernmost two-thirds so that's
overlooking their garden it is all
already present that's that would be
number one there so it's already there
yes it's not gonna make any difference
that's go that's not changing that
elevation is increasing the height or
anything that and then further on up
you've got the other two you've got the
one for the north of it that one is
right up against the boundary is there
any necessity for that it's about a
meter away the garage element which is
lower is on the boundary necessity I'm
sure there are other configurations that
would work on this site because you know
from that very bland looking gable side
of the building these people have got to
look at it's not exactly the most
attractive thing to look at so question
Paul confer that opposite mr. Upton's
house is there are they
[Music]
Nuka structure have a higher than the
bonds that worry there at the end of mr.
Upton's garden it's currently open sky
obviously but the the new the new
building will effectively replicate the
situation at the end of mr. mrs. Malins
garden which is the existing building
that's being refurbished so the new
building will echo that pretty much
precisely the counterbalance I thought
you said in your presentation that the
new build were lower than the Agra
called your building that were there
present
I'll get that wrong that's correct
counselor the ridge height you can see
there's not much in it it's about 20
centimeters but the rich height of the
new building is lower than the retained
between the concern with their neighbors
and the legal limit the the gable end of
the new building will be will meet the
standards
I take mr. opt-ins point about the
conservatory I've taken the view that
the distance is sufficient and the sort
of the amount of opens guide to north
and south is sufficient so what is the
distance from this new building that was
described as an open sky has now got
this building in it there's the
equivalent height to the existing
building to the left in that elevation
did you say it's 18 meetings to the
building but the object to here said it
wasn't I
twelve or something I mean what is that
distance to the conservatory between the
the gable end there and the rear
elevation as I've measured it on the
plans is 16 meters mr. Upton gives a
figure of 12 meters from his
conservatory I can't lean on the
accuracy and so that
he's got a west-facing view with this
elevation of it yes correct
counselor feeling Thank You councillor
Mills the materials I these are going to
be old brittle it Aminu brick have you
discussed sore have we got any
indication because you know don't want a
great big barracks looking thing
overlooking the other houses agree
counselor we have condition proposed
condition nine which requires materials
and photos of samples it inserts you to
be submitted before development proceeds
above ground level bricks and stone it's
wherever we specify so I would agree
that brick would be more appropriate for
just going back to the distance of
conservatory and the new build is there
a danger of overshadow or shadow on the
the conserved of the garden if I show
you the elevation again most of it is
single-story to the central part doesn't
form the majority of that elevation is
there a danger I mean there will be some
shadow in the garden I expect yet
whether whether that's whether that's
sufficient to sustain an objection under
policy cs9
is for councillors to judge councillor
fielding see waving on the other side if
they if the buildings are put on the
others other area to break up that one
long barracks what are the how far away
those houses sorry counselor I did miss
some of them
they they are further away and there is
a new development and hardly go on the
relatively new yeah there they are
further away no more questions can we go
to the debate who would be like to be
first counselor wrong Thank You chairman
I'm a bit surprised about this refuse
collection because I'm detecting some
inconsistencies because I've gotten a
situation in my ward where we decided in
consultation with the refuse collection
service this sort of distance was too
far to expect the residents to take
their refuse collection in view the
disability requirements for the future
and that was as I recollect a lot less
than 100 meters and as the objectors
have pointed out and I know this
juncture very well because it's less
than three miles away from my house the
idea that we're gonna get further I know
it's difficult collecting refuse but
this is a this is a difficult Junction
and I'm not happy with the idea that
residents have got to first of all take
their refuse that length of Drive and
then there's multiple pink lectures
there while the lorry loads them up I
think this is flawed in concept and I
think it's discriminatory against people
that have got got disabled problems or
then we required as a council to do pull
out which is the cost of the council I
think we should be designing it before
the future and I think we should we
should be able to get the refuse
collection up to the houses
and furthermore it does because the site
is presumably congested and because the
sauce congested we've got this long wall
facing these residents over it seems to
make and a softer loss of light now
whether the distance is 18 meters 9
meters 15 meters depayne how we measure
it it seems to me this is a long ridge
overshadowing the people we're going to
suffer the loss of life from the the Sun
to their garden in the afternoons in the
evening so I'm afraid at the moment I
listen to what everybody else is saying
but I think these are good reasons to
refuse this application Thank You
chairman Thank You counselor counselor
fielding I'm happy to go along with the
refusal I think that the existing
buildings they're fine but the other two
particularly the other one north of it
it's too over overbearing on the houses
on the other side it could be rejected
there's plenty of room to do it and I
just think it's very poor design on
quite honestly as it stands at the
moment I hope I don't like it I'm
surprised that there is no agent turning
up so we could question him and also
there's no parish council so another's
d2 council the ward member but he sort
of keeping quiet but I'm against it and
I refuse accountable to converse yes
I appreciate the parish council I'm the
ward member really limbo or whatever but
as far as I can see it's a tidying up of
the site not gain on the refuse
collection but we have to go along with
what the council got in the conditions
and I have problems with holiday lists
but it doesn't stuck on the side of the
road which year you know shouldn't
really be there but they have to be can
the collection can't get he did the
holiday lets the piccaboo simple as that
really
but I don't see with the reduction in
the height compared with their farm
buildings there is any major reason for
refusal but it could do with a bit of an
adjustment in councilor bonds there's it
being prompted by our solicitor of may
so that to clarify why counsel comes not
speaking because some you didn't
actually register to speak that correct
just my part um no sorry Peter
yeah I agree it's a totally bad design
site and you've got the majority of the
buildings up against the boundary I
think it needs a rethink on that okay
yeah so for my part when I saw it and I
sort of pulled up both side of it it was
a bit hairy round there I know that and
that was just a bit concerned about how
this what this is just rightly said
they're about this big collection and
they are just upon my own place um so
yes I've concerns on this application
Peter because we don't want to refuse it
but we did want it improved so on corner
Peter we haven't got an agent here we
haven't got anybody else
I think deferment maybe the my obviously
not agree but it was a way forward we
need to have good reasons to defer at
Peter or technically only we can oppose
the application but it does need a
seen a number of points councillor
fielding I'm gonna pose it on on the CS
15 the visual impact on the neighbors I
would also look at I think probably 15
again it doesn't sort of blend in there
is no sort of landscaping that well
sorry it is too overbearing on the
neighbors and quite honestly I do not
like the design poor quality design from
what I can see with regards to a game
the neighbors on the on the the clothes
on the right hand side it is that a
proposal I would second that chance if
we can add something about the loss of
light and I don't know how we can deal
with this business about the refuse
collection disability issues and the the
effect at the junction which is it is a
difficult Junction there but don't know
how we word that I don't know what
policy it would refer to that he spent a
lot of time on the on the policy I don't
know if officers can help us on that so
the loss of light and the transport the
refuse and the refuse collection and
impact on the returning at the end of
the highway
our officers help with finding the
particular reference in the in the
policy just to be clear accounts there
we is the objection to the refuse
collection on highways grounds or in its
own rights because it could be could we
could look at it either way well I think
one is consequential on the other
because we're requiring the refuse to be
taken
the Rope turnout and when it gets to the
road turnout I think that's creating
problems for traffic highways and
visibility and safety so I think there's
there's two things there and one is
consequential on the other the only
reason I ask is in the absence of a
highways objection it might be worth
just just treating it in its own right
possibly rather than I would defer to
offices advice on the best way of
handling that issue is to it's described
chairman I'm just thinking her chair I
mean would a person actually buy a
property who had to walk hundred
twenty-five hundred twenty meters to put
their bins I mean if they didn't want to
do that and they wouldn't buy the
property in the first place so I do have
a bit of a serious issue about that
you'd buy something closer to the road
and not walk coming 20 meters I don't
know if there is a disability regulation
about bins from the property to the road
character Rock well somehow we've used
it on another development and we've told
it a developer he's got to provide a
turning area because it's too far and I
think that was 60 meters so somehow as a
council we've decided that's a
requirement so I'm not quite sure what
policy we were invoking there but it
seems that there's an inconsistency
I don't know chair this is a private
drive I live up a private driver
wouldn't expect the bin cart to come up
my private drive I put them basically on
the public highway they collect them and
that's the way it works in my finish
that's why it should work
I think if we help fielding go on the
basic refusal on the ground supporters
I'm overbearing and everything else we
can then leave the bins etc for a revamp
of the scheme if if that is what they
want yes in terms of the carry distance
I lacked knowledge Chancellor Rock's
comments because I think that's a it's a
requirement in terms of the bill under
the building regulations but what we
have in front of us is a no objection
from both the county highway authority
and from our own Bing collection people
accepting this this proposed arrangement
we're in somewhat of a weak position
then to to counter an argument that that
that this has been this this arrangement
is supported by both technical like by
both sets of technical parties still we
have a proposal yes and the second just
come back and clarify so the reasons for
refusal in in broad terms are
unacceptable layout arrangement
impacting on adjoining neighbors the
design of the dwellings we can certainly
we can certainly talk in in terms of
lots of amenities to the particular
occupiers of number one three number
three number three the design
unacceptable design it's because
blank big black blank wall there it
looks sort of barrack like sorry can
show you perhaps thinking of the refuse
keen this is this is that's the just
wanted to check on the point of further
because it isn't a blank elevation
it's a red design design objection it's
in terms of the actual design of the
dwellings as opposed to their layout so
so design in terms of design of the
layout yeah what design of the layout so
the layout to see is a particular issue
you have relation to those legs sorry
did you say impact is impactful
neighbors impact on neighbors the
policies that you referencing those
would be serious
20 CS 9cs 15 and is 10 council rock yes
Gemma things been said CFCs 9 to
requires proposals to be sensitive
layout and orientation so I think if
that's if that's what we were saying
nothing CS 20 deals with neighbor of
amenities and in particular
thank you yes we'll go to vote so we
have a poke poser and a seconder to reap
to refuse this application to e in
accordance of those reasons
yeah and the reason Kim can vote paver
check mass at the detailed reasons the
deep the actual detail at the reasoning
is one understand she's agreed with the
with the chair will draft that tomorrow
okay so on that boat we go to refuse
that application yes yeah yep that's one
abstainer which station can you sit down
be web okay
just stretching your legs it's okay yeah
you need to promise to come back so you
can come back now counselor Crump
thank you catch the mouse and move on to
our last item on the agenda which is
virtual business no urgent business on
consider and we'll close the planning
committee thank you